good morning being 10 o'clock I will
call the committee to order for Senate
bill one I think we have Senator Carson
as supposed to be here and then she's
got to leave
she's in the hall
all right we're gonna we're gonna
accommodate her first because she had to
get back the Senate is holding up there
she is
Senator Carson is recognized to
introduce Senate bill one
good morning senator
excuse me
um it is a pleasure to be with you this
morning for the record my name is Sharon
Carson I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Londonderry
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill 1
which is relative to the closing of the
sununu youth center and establishing a
commission to study the public safety of
the secured Youth Development Center and
surrounding communities Mr chairman in
last uh the last biennium budget
a decision was made to close the sununu
center and it was given a really what
amounts to a drop dead date of March 1st
2023 it is now February 9 2023 and we
still do not have
um really anything in place so what we
really need to do today Mr chairman is
figure out a day
we've seen a couple of dates floating
around in the legislation that I filed
it was November 1st 2024 but I believe
that there are other dates out there and
really all I have to extend to the
committee is that we are going to work
with whatever you give us so and I'll be
more than happy to work with all of you
this is an issue that we must resolve
and so thank you very much Mr chairman I
appreciate your time and your
committee's time this morning
thank you Senator understand they're
holding up the Senate until you get back
so yes they are we won't need to have
you answer any questions thank you thank
you
okay let's see if we have any of the
other Senators here I don't see any
so the next card I have uh is from Holly
Stevens
Nami New Hampshire
welcome to finance committee
and if you have written testimony that
the clerk would appreciate that
good morning chairman Weiler members of
the committee the written testimony is
coming around and there are enough
copies for the clerk to take one for the
file as well as one for himself
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Holly Stevens I'm the
director of public policy at Nami New
Hampshire it's a national Alliance of
mental illness
Nami New Hampshire is a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of individuals
affected by mental illness and suicide
through education advocacy and support
I'm here today to speak in favor of
Senate Bill 1 as amended by the Senate
as it came over to you
um many children in the Juvenile Justice
System I know you've heard a lot of
testimony in the senior centers I'll
keep this brief for you this morning
many children in the juvenile justice
system are inapprop are there
inappropriately as a result of mental
health needs and the majority of
children in the Juvenile Justice System
have a diagnosable mental illness that
is the reason that Nami New Hampshire
has a strong interest in this bill
um this past earlier this week I would
was able to listen in on um division
three as they discussed other some new
new center bills and I just want to
bring forward as a result of listening
to those discussions
that um
if this committee does opt to delay the
closure of this new new center which is
you know Senate bill one
um kicks the can down the road a few
months but really you know looks at
getting the new building
um up and running as quickly as possible
and I know that there are discussions
about maybe delaying that even further
if this committee does ought to look at
delaying it for a couple of years Nami
New Hampshire strongly urges the
committee to look at the provision of
Senate bill one that starts the services
the trauma-informed care and the mental
health services for these kids to get
those started in the existing facility
as soon as possible
um you know it's something that's been
lacking in that facility and it's
something that's really in Need You Know
Senate bill one is a comprehensive
package and so we would prefer to see
this bill go forward as is but again you
know if this committee has other plans
just urge you to really consider getting
those Services into place I'm happy to
answer any questions
that's the end of my testimony
thank you questions from the committee
members from Miss Stevens
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair since Senator Carson brought it up
and it's being brought up by Nami uh I
the Senate Bill won on the closure date
has language that leaves it dependent
upon Tran the transfer of of the
residents out of there it's online two
of page two uh to line five it reads the
sysc shall immediately be closed for
detention or admission of any child when
the secure treatment facility authorized
by this chapter is sufficiently
completed the children can be legally
and safely housed there that that
language I think removes the the the
guillotine of a suspense date and
instead puts us on the path to finding
an appropriate replacement would nimi
does nimi support that that approach yes
because I mean sorry and Nami would
support that approach you know would be
obviously after the department to
determine when that facility was safe
for transfer so we would you know put
our trust in the department to be able
to do that safely
any further Committee Member have a
question
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Mr thank you
well next call upon Karen Rosenberg
disability rights I think it's
conference
welcome to finance committee thank you
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center and I'm here to encourage you to
support sb1 as amended by the Senate
um we're at a really critical juncture
right now in terms of treatment of
children who because of the danger they
might post the community but also their
own trauma and mental health issues have
ended up ordered to secure detention or
secure commitment for a brief period of
time and what this body and the
legislature figured out a couple years
ago is that the current sununu Center is
really not appropriate to meet the needs
of those children and what we really
need is for children to receive
treatment and for the community to be
safe but also for them to come out
better when than when they went in and
so after years of consideration well at
least a year
my understanding was that the consensus
was that what needed to happen was we
needed to have a small therapeutic
facility that would be staffed by people
who are trained in trauma-informed care
and that it would be able to provide the
education and therapy that children need
in order to be successful when they
leave and there's urgency around that
right because we know that right now the
facility is supposed to close in just a
few weeks but it's something that you
all have thought about for a really long
time and and I want and it's important
that this happened and that
the facility be able to appropriately
staff to maintain the safety of the kids
there and also the staff that are still
there it's not something that really can
be delayed I know I mean in my perfect
world we have no children locked up
right
um I am that bleeding hard right I don't
want to put any kids in jail but I
realized that day is probably not going
to come and I know there's some hope
that a bill can be worked on to tighten
the circumstances even further that
would enable a court to order a kiddo to
secure detention or secure commitment
but um I think that's something that
needs to be done in a thoughtful way our
former Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court noticed some issues when we tried
to rework that language I think that
could be done but I don't know that
that's going to solve the problem and at
this point it's really about treatment I
know there's a lot of squabbling about
size of this facility I think we're
talking about a really small facility I
don't believe in that if you build it
they will come
um you know Field of Dreams analogy
because we build 144 so bed facility at
the sununu center and we know that the
census there is generally around 12 to
upwards of 18 at the most kids so again
I encourage you to do the right thing
for kids and thank you so much I'm
willing to take any questions you might
have
any questions from committee members
first representative leishman and
representative McGuire
hi and thank you for taking my question
and you may not be the right person and
not knowing who's coming to put the
question out there
so in the amendment on page four on line
three
it says that in no event the new secure
Youth Development Center or facility
exceeds 15 million dollars
however
in the fiscal note the department of
administrative Services says it will at
least be I think
21.6 million dollars regardless of the
time frame you wouldn't
probably not the right person I've
listened to a lot of testimony about
this I think that director ribsum is is
your guy for those answers
um I mean so I'll put it out there
anyway yeah I mean I could just tell you
what I've heard but I think he's really
the go-to person or perhaps um Charlie
arlinghaus thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman
representative McGuire for question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming I want to ask a little more you
said that children should never be
locked up oh no in my perfect world
children would never need to be locked
up sorry
man yeah so
I would assume that a number of these
children
and the definition of children as being
under 18 yes have committed murder
and so is it is it makes sense that
if you commit murder under 18 no lock up
if you commit murder over 18 life in
prison or something like that that
doesn't like like I said I mean that's
you know in the we're not going to have
my ideal world right where no one
commits terrible crimes and no one needs
to be locked up but certainly I I don't
dispute what you're where you're going
with this if someone commits murder and
they're dangerous they're going to be
necessarily removed from society because
they're dangerous right but in the
meantime they are children they need to
have educational opportunities and you
know opportunities to live their lives
it may not be the life that their
parents or they would have envisioned
for themselves but we want to make sure
that we're treating them appropriately
as children
and committee members I have the
director ribsom here I'm saving him for
last kind of the cleanup guy on all the
all this uh testimony so that he can
answer the the detailed questions so
uh if some of those things you can say
for them uh represent whole you have a
question Ms Rosenberg you as the chair
right and maybe director ripson is the
right person asking stuff can we find a
list of the crimes that those that are
being detained right now have committed
just generically
perhaps the director will be able to
furnish that
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair following up with
representative McGuire at a sort of a
similar question but I'd like since
you're from Nami to go a little bit
further disability disability rights
thank you for correcting me
um in your perfect world or what is your
vision for dealing with students who
have some mental health issues dealing
with mental health issues and have
committed a violent crime what is what
do you see as the best way of treating
this the best way would be to help those
those children who most of them will be
returning to the community right so it's
to give them the skills that they need
to be able to manage their emotions and
behaviors and a lot of these students
and I think you'll hear this from
director ripson have experienced their
own trauma or abuse as young children
and what needs to happen is we need to
break that cycle and by implementing
evidence-based therapies making sure
they get their education that they need
um some of these kids a lot of these
kids have IEPs so they may not have
really strong reading skills these are
the kinds of things that we could start
accomplishing with children in an
appropriate facility so that they will
earn their High School diplomas learn
those coping skills and be able to
manage their anxiety and anger maybe but
in a in a socially appropriate way
any other member have any question
seeing none thank you Ms Rose thank you
all
the next call on Cassandra Sanchez from
the office of the child advocate
welcome to finance good morning thank
you for having me
for the record my name is Cassandra
Sanchez child advocate for the State of
New Hampshire
I am here in support of Senate Bill 1 as
amended by the Senate
I agree with much of the testimony
Before Me by Karen Rosenberg from the
DRC the focus does need to remain on the
children that access the facility and
the children that are currently in the
facility as Miss Rosenberg noted a lot
of these children have complex trauma
which means they need a setting that is
a treatment focused setting which means
trauma-informed care intensive
therapeutic services and opportunities
to learn
how to regulate their emotions on their
own so children who experience complex
trauma
unfortunately do not have the ability to
learn regulation through attachment as
normal developing children have the
opportunity to do and so in a setting
where they have therapy available to
them and the staff who are trained to
work with co-regulation they have the
ability to form those relationships with
the children and to teach them those
skills so that in the future they are
able to regulate on their own they're
able to manage their anger and they have
an opportunity to be more successful in
the community as adults that is what we
want to see for our children of New
Hampshire and although this is a large
cost now we see that if we invest in our
children now we will save in the long
run when they are adults and they are
able to be successful members of the
community
I also would like to address the comment
about children within the center that
may be in there for charges
such as murder or or seriously violent
crimes and I want to clarify that those
numbers are very very low maybe one or
two children but that is extremely rare
and they are low numbers in our state so
we are not building a facility for
that we're expecting to fill with
children who engage in extremely violent
crimes it is a chance for children to go
and rehabilitate and return to the
community and hopefully to not return
back to the facility if the if the care
that they need and the therapies are
available to them in that setting
please let me know if you have any
questions thank you
thank you for your testimony any
Committee Member have a question
Miss Sanchez
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
all right the next next card I have I
guess the others that have wanted to
speak have turned in their pink cards I
see some
alumni here that might want to speak but
they haven't turned in a card
so I will next call on director Joe
ribson
director of the Department of Children
Youth and Family
thank you
good morning director welcome back good
morning thank you for having me uh for
the record Joe ribson director of dcyf
um being passed around right now is some
data I know some of this data has been
shared with all of you at least the
first front page or with the whole the
entire committee at a prior hearing the
next two pages is data that had only
been previously shared with division
three so I thought it would be useful to
share that here as well
um before I get into that
uh there's a few things that I'd like to
talk about one we do fully support sb1
and we think it's time for us to move
forward from the history of what we've
seen at sysc we think that sb1 sets
forth an appropriate plan both in terms
of physical structure security also
though programming treatment integration
into the broader system of care that
we've built for children into the state
and I'm going to spend time hopefully if
if you'll indulge me going through the
aspects of the bill that do that because
I know when Senator Carson introduced it
she didn't have the opportunity to kind
of walk folks through that before we get
into that though there's just a couple
things I want to kind of Orient folks to
looking at the data so has this come
around to everybody
okay so the very front page there what
you're looking at here is the average
daily population not even the average
the actual daily population of every day
from July 1 2016 until January 1 2023.
and you see that in 2016 which is
shortly before I came here and um you
know before we made a lot of big changes
to the system we were sometimes peaking
up around 75 kids at the facility at a
time
and you see that for really the past
almost three years since the early 2020
we've been kind of hovering in this the
average daily census has been 12 but
it's kind of bounced around the absolute
bottom that we've gotten to was five
kids and that actually was only in
November of this year and the absolute
Peak was 18 kids and that was actually
only a few weeks ago
so the census can move rather
dramatically rather quickly
and you know for clarification purposes
too right dcyf Juvenile Justice and sysc
don't decide who goes to sysc that's the
decision that courts make that's a
decision the judges make
right we have influence on some of that
but we don't make those decisions so we
don't have control over who comes and
goes from sysc we have influence but not
control so from the EXT from the extent
that the idea is that um somehow you
know we dcyf or we sysc can can limit
the senses ourselves we really can't do
that what does that and what has done
that successfully in the state are two
different things one changing the laws
about who gets in and two changing the
system to better support kids so they
don't need to come in and part of me I'm
fighting a cold I don't have covet I've
taken tests every day but I am very dry
so when you look at this data you see
really a big rapid decrease starting in
and two things happened around that time
number one the laws were changed as to
who could be detained and committed
limiting who you know the types of
offenses that could go there in the
first instance to serious serious
offenses and also
um misdemeanor offenses for repeated
instances right so the typical repeated
misdemeanor offense that you would see
go into sysc under the new Under the
current law is repeated simple assaults
and repeated domestic violence incidents
so incidences where there's violence in
the household between a child and their
parent or a child and another child you
know or sometimes they'll get charged
with simple assaults or it might be
charged as a simple assault coming out
of a residential program
towards staff and then coming into syc
those are the typical misdemeanors that
you see coming into sysa otherwise it's
typically
um you know your higher level offenses
that are coming in
the chart the green line is the total at
any given time
the orange line or the red line is the
number of detained youth and the purple
line is the number of committed youth
just to orient folks detained means for
the most part that your pending
adjudication you're waiting for the
court to determine whether or not the
offense has been committed and whether
or not you should be committed to the
facility or some other disposition
should be rendered there are some other
youth that fall into that category
within our system
um
a regular detained youth that I just
described will typically be there for
maybe a matter of days or weeks at most
um but there are some longer term
detained Youth and those would be young
people who do commit extremely serious
offenses and are charged as adults we
don't see that over utilized in New
Hampshire I've only seen it happen a few
times and it happens around really
serious crimes like murder
um and some other very serious offenses
and when a young person is charged with
a crime like that they do remain with us
on detained status pending that entire
stay right so they could often stay with
us for years on a detained status
and again that's depending on how the
court processes work the other
population that can come in on a short
term like that is what you call the icj
interstate compact for juveniles we only
get about
really about five kids a year and under
the interstate compact for juveniles
um they can only be here for about five
days and what that is is if a child from
another state commits a defense here and
they get arrested and detained and then
sent back to their home state and their
home state has to come pick them up it's
reciprocal we have to do the same if one
of our kids do something in another
state or if a kid gets picked up here
and it turns out they have a warrant for
a serious arrests at another state and
then they could be sent to sysc and
detained their pending the other state
coming up to pick up that kid so those
are kind of the populations that make up
that detained group and then the
committed group or the group that
there's been an adjudication that
they've committed a serious offense and
the court believes that uh commitment at
sysc is the appropriate disposition
under current law for most defenses
they're eligible for parole after three
months
and for some more serious offenses
they're eligible for parole after six
months most of the time they are granted
parole at that point
so the average length of stay for a
committed youth is actually closer to
three months since the six month term
doesn't doesn't get implemented too
often
um but so that's why our census is low
from the legal perspective the other
reason why the census has gotten down so
low and before I get into that something
I should have mentioned earlier is that
the lowest combined rate of detained and
committed kids in the entire country
there is one state that has
fewer detained kids according to the
data in this report which I shared with
division three I didn't print out a
million copies for everybody today
the state that has fewer detained kids
is mean they claim to have zero detained
kids which I don't really believe
because I also have a program that they
call shock incarceration which I think
is just a different word for detention
so I think it's a semantics issue
and when you add up their committed
population versus our detained and
committed combined were lower
the state that has fewer committed kids
is Connecticut they probably do have
fewer committed kids actually but when
you add their detained population to
their committed population we're lower
so when I say combined population is the
lowest in the country that's what I'm
talking about if you go through the data
in this report you will see there are
two states that on those individual
measures are better but as a combined
measure we're the lowest
that's to say that you know as much hope
as I have to continue to drive this
number down there's not a lot of
national precedence for doing so
and I think you know we have to keep
that in mind when we're thinking about
how we're moving the system forward and
how aggressive we want to be and moving
um you know the the size of the facility
and capacity of facility
so if we turn to the next page this
tells another part of the story
so this is the daily count of Juvenile
Justice service youth involved in
residential placement settings
now
if the only thing that happened was the
laws changed and we couldn't keep kids
in a secured setting you would
anticipate I would anticipate that what
you would see was those kids would move
from a secured setting to a non-secured
setting
and if you look at the data and you look
at this data here you do see in 2018
when that law first changed you see it
starts to climb right you see the system
immediately react by sending more kids
to Residential Care
and then it very quickly starts to go
down and what what's happening there
where it's going down is the system of
care that we've all been talking about
and building
both parties everybody agreeing that we
need to meet children's Behavioral
Health Care needs in the community is
starting to serve kids and starting to
work with kids and keeping kids from
having to be in
out of home placements whether it's sysc
or Residential Care
um I will say when you look further down
this data you want to be careful when
you get into
into the kind of 2020 leader because
what you see here is a big collapse at
the start of covid
and right now we're in a place where
Workforce is really suppressing our
capacity so there's probably more demand
than where than we're accessing right
now so I don't want to claim that what
you're seeing here at the end of 2022 is
is where the system would be if
everything was functioning well it
probably is a little higher than that
but in any instance the trajectory on
the residential side is also steeply
down
so
if we flip to the next page
representative Edwards wants to question
something on you sure thank you Mr chair
I think the question is relevant to this
particular graph and you've shared this
with the division three before so I've
had a chance to think about it
some people have
posited that if we build a facility a
replacement facility with a capacity of
x
that when that kid if that kid shows up
that makes it X plus one shows up to to
where we're no longer within our
capacity what that would trigger would
would be kind of a two-step process one
the least dangerous kid in in that's
already in the facility could basically
be discharged and moved into one of
these residential facilities and and I'm
and I'm just curious about two aspects
of that you know what what is our what
is our legal flexibility for moving
somebody out of the facility and and
what is the capacity you think in the
residential setting to take those kinds
of kids that that maybe need the Sue new
new security but we're moving them into
a less secure environment so there's two
components of that if you wouldn't mind
yeah so there is there's historical
precedent at the facility prior to my
time there
um for the old facility actually
reaching Max Capacity not even the new
sysc building but the prior campus
setting reaching Max Capacity and
there's a provision in law for something
called administrative release which is
allowable and that's utilized and we
still utilize that today but not to
manage capacity what it's used for is
when you have a kid who's actually
clinically ready to step down and you
don't want to make them wait around for
parole for that purpose so you have them
step down and then clinically
um you know they're assessed they're
managed they're stepping down they come
back for parole and parole will will
bless that decision at the time that the
parole hearing is held that's the
process that was used historically when
the facility reached capacity
um
that's a process that we currently only
use for committed kids not detained kids
you know advice that I've gotten in the
past was that that process really is
only authorized for committed kids not
detained kids I have heard lawyers tell
me that they think that's not accurate
advice and that you could use it for
detained kids I
I want to be careful not to misstep on
that and not to interpret that right but
that's I have heard debate from lawyers
on on that on that issue
that being said right this is a process
that's safely used when you've gone
through an assessment and you've
determined that that a kid's clinically
ready to step down we don't want to keep
a kid locked up any longer than we have
to right
um
you'd hope not to use it just because
you don't have space to just because you
don't have space but there is a process
for that now in the second part of your
question around the residential system
the residential systems undergoing a
massive redesign in the past few years
and I this is I could talk for hours
about this stuff
um the the way that we redesigned the
system the old system was
um was a vendored system right where we
had a basic standards Medicaid rule
providers could prove demonstrate that
they're meeting that basic standards
rule we certified them as meeting that
rule and a rate was established for them
there was actually in the budget bills
for 10 years up until a few years ago
there was actually language saying that
a provider resident provider could not
have their rate increased so you had
providers who had their rates struck 15
years ago who had their rates Frozen for
that whole period of time
and they were only required to kind of
meet these minimum basic standard rules
under Medicaid to fix this we decided to
procure the whole system put it out for
a competitive bid and then Implement new
standards and new requirements for those
providers so new standards around
clinical ratios the types of care that's
provided creating different levels of
care different levels of intensity
depending on the needs of the kids
something called six core strategies to
reduce restraint and seclusion which is
a model that I used back when I was in
New Jersey to help reduce the use of
restraint and seclusion in facilities
requiring them all to become accredited
agencies
a host of other things that I'm not
remembering right now but we put the
whole system out to bid and then kind of
redesigned the system around this
the structure and this idea of different
levels of Care at the same time we
started something called the cat
assessment the comprehensive assessment
for treatment where you have a clinician
an independent clinician come in and
actually assess what the kids needs are
and tell us you know where on these
levels will this kid have their need met
believe it or not we never did anything
like that before people were using their
professional judgment and trying to just
do the best they could with the system
we had right it was a bit of a it was a
bit of a messy system right because you
had
all these providers meeting minimum
basic standard rules providing the type
of care that they wanted serving only
who they wanted to serve and staff just
doing their best to try to manage within
that so there's now some structure
around all of this that's that's
starting to work and starting to
transform that system
um so we have contract capacity which is
plenty adequate but we do not have
actual capacity that's adequate at this
moment and that's because of the
workforce issues so right now at this
exact moment the residential system and
that's why I said I'd be careful
interpreting the data
in these later years as being kind of
the ceiling because there's kind of an
artificial cap on capacity because
there's not enough work for us so a lot
of these facilities have units that are
closed down and beds that are not open
because I can't hire enough people to to
fill the beds that's one of the key
things contributing to the Ed you know
wait list and all those types of things
on a Hampstead wait list too it was kids
getting backed up waiting for these
types of programs so the answer is
structurally for a committed kid there's
a process for that the system itself at
this exact moment probably can't handle
it if the workforce issues are someday
resolved for you know there's there's a
little more flexibility and hope to be
able to do that
questions from the committee
representative papovichi Muller
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
director for taking the question
one of the points that was made I was uh
taking uh you know this back seat when
uh Finance three was meeting was that
points would have made that there are
alternatives to building our own
facility that there are facilities
outside the state or you know private
facilities that we could use for
situations like that that was mostly
referred to in terms of align concerns
over the capacity of the facility but of
course one could see that as a temporary
placement for the facility if the
legislature doesn't uh you know provide
a replacement could you comment on that
and talk more about the topic so we
understand your perspective on it I'm
happy to comment on that there's also a
little more I wanted to walk through on
on the data and on the actual bill so
that's kind of moving into a new topic
I'm happy to wait
which way you'd like me to go
uh we'll we'll proceed for you to finish
up page three okay so again going to the
this issue around right you've seen
reduced utilization of sysc at the same
time contrary to what people would
naturally assume that these kids would
all show up in residential care you're
seeing reduced utilization of
residential where they're showing up
instead is actually in the system of
care so what you're seeing here is the
data for a program called fast forward
this is the flagship program of the New
Hampshire children's system of care and
what this program does is it provides
High Fidelity wraparound services and
what that is is you have a clinical
person who provides Care Management
and it's not just Care Management in the
way where you think about where you're
calling your you know your insurance
company and they're trying to direct you
to the providers right they actually
hold meetings on a monthly at least
monthly basis and they pull together all
the people who are important in a kid's
life right the parents of course the kid
of course
if they're involved with child
protection Child Protection workers
should be there if they're involve a
juvenile justice Juvenile Justice should
be there any clinicians that are working
with the kids the schools anybody else
who's important to the kid right
grandparents if they're important
members of their faith community whoever
it is it's important you want to create
this team of natural supports to wrap
around a kid that's what the words wrap
around really talk about and it also has
components to have in-home Clinical
Services for the kids and peer support
through Nami New Hampshire who we heard
from this morning and peer support for
the both for the parents through Nami
New Hampshire and then also for the
Youth and what you see with a program
like that it was the same exact model
slightly slight variations with the same
service package in New Jersey is that
the need for having kids out of home and
away from their communities goes down
over time and when it really gets
exciting is when you start getting to
these kids when they're eight nine ten
and they never become these 16 17 year
olds who end up going to places like
sysc at all right so what we're seeing
here today is one the system of care is
already removing pressure from the
juvenile justice system and I would say
that in the future you would expect it
to remove more pressure from the
juvenile justice system that being said
the idea that you know that I'm ready to
bank on or commit to the idea that a
much smaller facility than 18 is
something that we could than an 18
capacity with the idea that you're
serving 12 kids you know is something
that I do get nervous about given that
there is not a state in the country
that's proven that that's possible yet
so
with that on the data I'm happy to take
questions on that or I'm happy to walk
through the bill chairman or I'm happy
to answer the question that was asked
thank you I have a couple of questions
first representative Petrie then
representative buco
oh thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you for taking my question and uh
on this uh
I bet uh how many kids are subject to a
visual offender if there are any because
at some point you know enough is enough
so under current law
as I said before
they could be committed to sysc for a
single felony a higher level serious
felony offense or for multiple lower
level offenses that include some
violence including things like simple
assault and domestic violence those are
actually the types of situations that we
see more of than anything else our young
folks that have repeated instances of
violence within the household or within
you know other types of settings
so it is you know it's typical to have
multiple instances I do have some data
similar to what representative who asked
about because representative erf asked
me a question similar question a couple
weeks ago
it'll be hard for me to read on my phone
but I can pull it up and walk through a
sample of that for folks if you would
like
but it is very common for the young
people who end up there to have to have
had multiple offenses before they go
there
right I heard you mentioned shock and
incarceration in Maine
and uh I heard or I I listened and you
said you're from New Jersey or you
worked in New Jersey which they have a
Scared Straight program how effective is
the Scared Straight program and do we
still
I I know that uh I think we've shied
away from that but uh yeah it was quite
and and and of course we got Abbott
districts in New Jersey which you know I
mean they're struggling to try to get
these kids in school and get an
education yep
yeah you know I think I think what we've
seen you know New Jersey's seen a rapid
decline as well not as much as we've
seen here already
um of course there's also different
challenges in New Jersey around you know
really ingrained intergenerational
poverty and things that while it occurs
here it's not at the same rate that you
see in some of these other places
um
what I would say is I think what we saw
there and what we're seeing here is that
one of the things that makes the biggest
difference is actually providing
early easy needs-based access to
Children's Behavioral Health Care and
supporting parents through that process
that makes the biggest difference the
other things that make big differences I
think are really finding ways to support
those households where parents are
struggling because a lot of what you see
is young people living a really unstable
situations and then you know that's kind
of what you're seeing playing out you
know it's the trauma that they've
experienced as young people programs
like scared straight and stuff like that
I think they they could work for certain
populations of kids
um you know a young person who really
already has a very stable home
environment and really isn't struggling
with these other external factors and
you know they did they made a stupid
mistake and it's the kind of thing that
they're like oh wait I'm not going to
make that mistake again
um honestly for a lot of those young
people I think just the process of being
arrested one time is probably enough to
scare them straight I don't know that
those programs have been terribly
effective when you're really working
with kids who have long histories of
trauma Behavioral Health needs
challenges around intergenerational
poverty and things like that
representative bucco for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you director
for coming today I'd like to move to the
uh fiscal note down at the bottom here
it says that this appropriation will be
funded by federal funds Opera funds are
those still available
yes so and what and how how much is that
you know included
sure so the
the governor's budget director came to
the Senate was was asked to come to the
Senate finance committee hearing and
talked about this so I'm just going to
repeat what I heard them say because I'm
not the expert on the arpa funds or on
any of those things right that's outside
of my my world but what was testified to
then was that there was 15 million
dollars of arpa funds put in reserved
for this purpose
um and that those funds are available
excuse me there's an additional figure
here of 20 21.6 what what kind of
estimate are you guys working with yeah
so you know that is a complication so
this there's a long tortured history
here that some people in the room are
familiar with and some are not but this
is a process that's been happening for
well some might say decades but at least
a few years and
um so last year there was a commission
our committee put together specifically
for the purpose of looking at this
problem and coming up with a
recommendation the only remaining member
of that Committee in the legislature is
uh sitting down down for me
representative Edwards the other four
members are no longer in the legislature
anymore and that was last uh last fall
or you know fall before last so about 18
months ago at that time the estimates
for building the new facility were
brought in by
um division or department so the the net
difference there you know is probably
represented by that although again the
fiscal note was completed by Department
of administrative services division
Public Works and they would be the
experts on on that
thank you
representative Edwards for
thank you Mr chair this is sort of a
follow-up to the previous question as I
heard you
uh we we've got this administrative
release process for we know it's for
kids that are committed and it if they
have achieved sort of a clinical
Readiness then they may qualify for the
administrative relief or release and
they go through a judicial review and
parole process
okay so I'm just I'm just wondering
about a couple of the other scenarios
there where let's say the facility is
full
none of the kids in there are clinically
ready
you know what what what what could we do
with them it doesn't sound like the
administrative release process is
appropriate to them
uh we would we would we ship them out of
state to secure facility would we what
what what happens for that X plus one
kid when all acts need to stay in the
facility it would be a real real
challenge
um you know there is not at this moment
another state that's willing to take
these kids you could ask our neighbors
in Vermont about their experience when
they chose to close their facility
without a plan or a new building in
place
we agreed to take their kids for a
period of time and entered into a
contract to do the same and eventually
our own Workforce issues were such that
we couldn't do that anymore and we had
to terminate that contract
um and I still get calls cut every
couple weeks asking if I'm willing to
change my mind and you know we're just
not in a position to do that
um but Maine is also not in a position
to do that in nor is Massachusetts at
least at this juncture so there's not
another state with a secured facility
that's really willing to step into that
space right now so it would be it would
be a real problem I think you know we'd
be stuck scrambling trying to figure out
what's the safest next best thing for
that for that scenario
quick follow-up but but what I'm hearing
I think is is that there is no standard
operating procedure of how that would
happen that that would in fact be a
break glass situation where we've got a
a kid in need and we've got public
safety issues with no pre-planned way of
handling it either legally or clinically
yep at this point at this point there's
not a process for for that scenario
other than the like I said the
administrative release process which
really is ideally used for kids who are
clinically ready it was like I said
years ago maybe a decade ago used to
manage capacity but you have to remember
a decade ago they were housing kids
there that were quite different than
today right when they had well over 100
kids on that campus you know that there
were lots of kids there that frankly by
today's standards had no business being
there
representative Sweeney has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here and taking our questions so
back to the fiscal note of 21.6 million
for the design and construction of the
new facility uh for 18 beds that's about
1.2 million per bed obviously we've
heard testimony about small therapeutic
spaces for this facility can you sort of
go into detail about what the vision is
for the design elements or or what how
are we getting to 1.2 million dollars
per bed that we're constructing here so
if you actually look in in the bill
section
the inspection two Roman three it kind
of goes through all the things that are
expected to be in this building and one
of the things that you know
that I think was even though I think
sysc has designed has a lot of flaws in
terms of being really really leaning too
far Correctional not having the
therapeutic components that we need one
thing that it did do was it actually was
a fully secured building which was not
the case of the old campus right the old
campus prior we're not all secured
buildings there was lots of issues
around Youth absconding and all types of
you know things happening in the
community and at this point right the
concentrated population of Youth that
are there I think you do want to have a
fully architecturally secured building
and to manage that you really have to
have your building be kind of self
self-sufficient self-contained so a lot
of the components it's not just about 18
bedrooms not like a house with 18
bedrooms but it's kind of all the
components that you'd have to imagine
that a young person needs access to have
to be built into that so that's kind of
why that that inflates that number grows
but if you look through Roman 3 on page
two right a talks about the design being
therapeutic trauma-reformed home-like
interior exterior to the maximum extent
practicable talks about setting it up in
a way that there's staff visibility to
ensure safety so you're not talking
about multiple floors and kids all over
the place but rather lots of glass lots
of ability for staff to see what's
happening to be able to respond you're
talking about having space for medical
needs to be met for kids
physical and behavioral health care
needs to be met so physical you're
really talking about both indoor and
outdoor recreational space these kids
need opportunities for large muscle
movement and we're living in New
Hampshire we can't really count on
outdoor large muscle movement all year
round
adequate space for educational needs so
we're not talking about a big massive
school but you need some classroom space
some computer space for educational
needs to be met
itional needs now
the current facility has a big
commercial kitchen if we were say to
co-locate this facility near another
facility where we could get the food
brought over we wouldn't need to build a
commercial kitchen so that would end up
being some savings I think the current
fiscal note is anticipating we would
build a full commercial kitchen because
that's what the current facility has
that being said we will still need the
cafeteria space right for the kids to
have their food but we wouldn't need the
full commercial kitchen
um
things around you know being
architecturally secure equipped with
video surveillance
um but really that kind of sets forth
the different components but I think
what's really critical here is just the
idea that you kind of have to build
everything in one space in One Secured
space that a kid would need unlike you
know in the real world where where we
have people coming and going to get
their needs met in all different places
one follow-up
follow-up thank you Mr chairman thank
you for for detailing that
I guess
in the broader picture of providing the
rehabilitation services that we're
seeking to provide to these children if
you were to have a scale in front of you
and one half of the scale was facility
needs and the other half were Personnel
therapeutic professional needs to
actually provide the Staffing and
retaining the staff to provide the
therapeutic care that is going to
actually make a difference an impact
which would you weigh is more important
is it the facility or is it the
Personnel staff that were able to hire
and retain to treat the children yeah I
mean honestly I think it's it's really
both in that a well-designed facility
complements the latter right and that's
again something that the current
facility doesn't do but when this when
this bill on um in Roman 3A talks about
complementing the therapeutic and
trauma-informed care of children really
talks about designing these spaces in a
way that don't feel and look
Correctional and that actually have you
know adequate spaces for for clinical
interventions for group sessions for
therapists to work with their kids and
such so I do think it's it's it's a it's
really about doing both of these things
well and doing it in a way that that
complements both but the programming is
absolutely key and that's really what
the next part of this Bill gets into if
you look at Roman 4 on that same page
you know really talks about Shifting the
staff qualifications and the things that
we're looking for in our staff and our
training up our current staff to help
get them to the point that we want them
to get to to be able to do this work
talks about bringing in evidence-based
practices for these kids which is
critical and which frankly we cannot do
today because our Workforce issues are
the way that they are right these
evidence-based models and these
trauma-informed models require that you
have a stable Frontline milieu Workforce
who are
seeing these kids and interacting with
these kids on a daily basis because
that's where the interaction happens
it's not just your clinician seeing your
kid a few times a week it's the it's the
micro interactions that happen between
kids and and their staff
um and right now we're in a place where
we have so few full-time staff because
of you know because of one the fear of
this building closing in three weeks and
two some challenges around around salary
which I'm hopefully are going to be
addressed through the collective
bargaining process that's happening
right now
um that it's just not possible to
implement those programs and I think
getting to the other side of this bill
and having a vision for the future is
going to help us get to the point of
being able to do those those programs
with the kids it talks about something
that we've not done
um until recently which is actually
stopped treating sysc like some kind of
Island unto itself and bring it into the
broader system of care for children so
and that's what C is about C talks about
using the same uniform assessment when I
talked about the assessment that's used
for residential care that's what C is
talking about here we're going to use
that exact same assessment it
cross-references the exact same statute
for the kids at sysc so that when a kid
goes to sysc we can do an assessment and
if we see this kid actually would
benefit from a level three residential
program and they're safe to do that then
we can start working towards that
immediately and not necessarily keep
them in a locked facility
um Dee talks about provision of Care
Management Services so when I talked
about fast forward before that's the
Care Management entity for the state
there's a different sub-component of
that Care Management called track and
I'm not remembering what that acronym
stands for right now but what Trek is
it's the same exact High Fidelity
wraparound model but it's for kids in
residential care including sysc for the
purpose of working with that team to
figure out how do you safely discharge
that kid back to the community or to a
step down program and get them out of
the higher level care that they're in so
that's what D is about it's about
building that piece for sysc kids so
that they're also crossed over with the
children's system of care
foreign
e really talks about making sure that
kids have frequent opportunities with
their families which is another key
piece educational programming and F
another key piece clinical work and
large muscle movements another key piece
so really this piece of it really gets
into all those key programmatic parts of
the facility so that's what's really
great about this bill is it's not just
about building a building and it's not
just about a number of beds it actually
sets forth the plan for
what do you want this to look like how
do you integrate it into the rest of
your system as a whole and what type of
programming do we want within the
facility to make sure that these kids
get the best care that we can give them
so
members I have two more with questions
uh we're coming up on we're delaying the
review for House Bill 527 the plan is to
have a recess from this division three
has a an amendment they want to review
that they worked on yesterday so we'll
be recessing this and coming back again
at 1 30. uh or one yeah I think we have
it at 130. we'll be coming back again so
we'll
hoping we can finish up some of this we
have another card from representative
Kirk it hasn't come in yet so
representative uh McGuire for a question
then representative walner thank you
very much Mr chairman
um take a look at your first page in
February of 20. there was a peak of 25
individuals and that's because the the
peak is the sum of two sort of random
numbers and the and the if you look at
the Blue Line in the orange line they
they both peaked at the same time right
and I don't see any particular reason
why later on they couldn't also Peak at
the same time and you'd have you'd want
25 but only have 18 is that right it's
so it's a possible risk right I think
right when you look at this you're
looking at three three years worth of
data and that's kind of early on in the
system of care intervention so I would
hope but again that is that is a
possible risk
um at the same time we have days where
we got down to five right so I think you
know the the the data tells us that 18
is a safe
ceiling even though we're really
designing this building and this program
to work for 12 kids because that's what
our average daily census has been for
the past you know close to three years
well the the past three years may have
been a little weird right so
um but let me ask you a different thing
on page five of the bill there's
established a commission to study the
situation is this a case of you know
we're doing something and then figuring
out later what we should be doing so my
opinion on this and I'm sure there are
people sitting around this table that
disagree with me my opinion on this is
that this issue has been studied
extensively over a very long period of
time about what we should do there is a
committee report that that
representative Edwards was on a couple
years ago there's a report a couple
years prior than that shortly after I
got to the state that another committee
put out which admonishes the legislature
and the administration for not making a
decision on this issue yet and that was
back in 2018.
um I think I think we kind of know where
the right direction is in my opinion
what this was about was um within the
Senate there was a lot of concern when
the idea of where this facility could be
located came up particularly the idea
that we're talking about three possible
sites and we haven't done yet the work
with the Architects
um to to do the to do kind of the the
um forgetting the words but the
the assessment of the actual locations
to determine whether they're appropriate
to build the building so there's three
possible locations that you could do
this that are being thought of today one
would be near New Hampshire hospital
reason for that would be that you could
co-locate and have some shared services
which would allow you to drive down
operational costs over time
substantially right now sysc operates in
a bubble so we run our own medical
program our own nutrition program we
manage this whole campus we have all
these folks who are working on on all
kinds of stuff that could be shared with
another facility if we were next to
another facility that would drive down
operational costs year after year over
time and these are all general fund
costs this is not right now funds that
the feds contribute to
um so near New Hampshire hospital is one
site near Hampstead Hospital is another
site again another opportunity to
co-locate have shared services over time
achieve some economies of scale
um and then the last option you know
which which my personal opinion would be
the least favorite option would be to
remain somewhere on the current campus
uh that would be my least favorite
option for two reasons one you wouldn't
have the shared services cost so you'd
still kind of be operating on an island
and two right we're all familiar with
the history of that property and I do
think it's I think there's value in
having a clean break and and getting
away from that
um so what this really was about was was
an opportunity for the legislators and
community members in whatever Community
this is cited in to be able to
participate in a process to figure out
like how are we going to make sure that
this is not going to have an adverse
impact on the community in which it's
situated and that they can have a voice
into what the security structures and
things look like so this wasn't really
about figuring out the entirety of
what's next but really that sub issue of
of kind of community impact
representative wellner for
location was the question I was going to
ask and I think you just outlined the
three locations you're looking at thank
you thank you
represent Edwards last question and then
I'm going to hear from representative
Kirk and then I'm going to go into
recess so we can get to the next bill uh
thank you Mr chair for the Indulgence I
on the question about the purpose of the
commission
is it right that the last few things
that you said are really the major
points of this commission that this
commission doesn't have any uh
decision-making Authority its Authority
is limited to writing a report
and proposing legislation
and that its key function is to begin
the conversations in a deep level with
each of the potential affected
communities
and and that because that hadn't been
taking place the greatest anxiety in the
senate about this bill was over the
select the site selection and the lack
of community involvement so so it wasn't
wasn't it in fact the purpose of this
commission to to deal with the
socialization issue of of how we pick a
site and what we do to respect our
responsibilities to that location yes
yeah that's accurate thank you for that
um and also on the very first page of
the bill I think it's in the third
paragraph there is language in there
around you know the department
accommodating the reasonable requests of
the community within which this is
ultimately placed in language and
they're about implementing a payment in
lieu of taxes to try to offset so
there's not an adverse Community impact
to wherever this ends up being placed
foreign
thank you representative Kirk is
recognized to speak
The Honorable Neil Kirk
thank you Mr chairman uh
good morning to you and to members of
the committee for the record I'm Neil
Kirk I live in Ware and today I'm
representing myself
um I appreciate the opportunity to speak
to you because I have a different take
on this bill
um I think the bill as it came before
you uh is should not be adopted by the
committee but it should be substantially
amendment to do amended to do two very
important things
number one deal with the cutoff date of
March 1st that has to be extended and
number two to the extent it's necessary
provide additional funds for the
Department to operate the facility
for the next four months from March 1st
through the end of the fiscal year
everything else that's in this bill
can be done at a later time by the
legislature when it has a
more time to do it either through the
budget process or through the retained
Bill process
and let me explain why I think this is
the right thing to do
I've been working on this problem since
at least 2015.
and you can see things move at glacial
Pace in this legislature
uh
the issue today facing us is primarily
the question of size and to some extent
location
the bill before you is the Senate
version
of the solution to this problem
the house version
to the solution to this problem which
went through a number of iterations and
collapsed in a conference committee last
year
has a very different take
children and family law wanted a six bed
facility
um with a whole variety of changes to
the kinds of children who could be
either detained or committed to sununu
and
that's there been their position for a
number of years three or four times this
has happened so what you see before you
is an effort by the Senate
to do what they were unable to do in
conference committee
last during the last budget
we know that we've put in a system of
care for these children and that system
of care is very effective and even the
department agrees that over time
we are going to reduce the population
still further of the sununu center
we don't know exactly how low it will go
and we don't know when it will occur but
it will occur because the system of care
is dealing with the younger children now
so that they will not
become eligible for sununu they will not
be engaged in the kinds of activities
which the sununu center is an
appropriate place
if you act now to build a facility of 12
to 18 beds
which is what the bill requires and it
turns out over the next couple of years
and remember Das says this building
cannot be completed before 2026.
um you may be building a facility for 12
to 8 with 12 to 18 beds when the
population only requires six to twelve
let's slow it down before we go in that
direction of of the Senate bill
we have other opportunities and you've
seen how complex this issue is you've
heard uh Mr ribson's testimony this is a
very complicated area and for the
finance committee which is supposed to
deal only with Finance issues to get
involved with all of these Children and
Youth and Family Law positions might be
inappropriate sometimes you have to do
it we've done it in the budget but it's
not a desirable thing to do and since
House Bill 120 which is the clone of of
Senate bill one is already retained in
children and family law we have an
opportunity for that committee to do its
job and decide what they want to do
rather than Finance taking the Senate
position
and not doing what the house really
wants or at least children and family
law wanted
some of you know that YDC which the
predecessor Youth Development Center
detention or Development Center
Development Center uh the predecessor of
the sununu center also had the same
kinds of
um
legal problems at the sununu center now
has
one of the questions that I think both
children and family law and this
committee should ask is whether or not
we want to create a mini sununu Center
which might have the same problems
because it might carry over the same
culture
and what is the definition of insanity
doing the same thing again and expecting
a different result
so
let me conclude by asking the committee
to change the spill to deal with the
immediate problem
extend the date or eliminate the date
and put in some funding if necessary
and leave the rest of the issues to the
children and family law committee and or
the budget depending upon what the
circumstances are
but this committee I don't think should
abandon the house position in the face
of a Senate bill
thank you Mr chairman I'd be pleased to
ask answer any questions if there are
any I hope there's only one
representative leishman
thank you very much Mr chairman nice to
see the former chair of the finance
committee you were probably sitting on
finance at the time or was in the house
when the sununu center was built and I
know a substantial amount of federal
funds were used to build that facility
do you know where that would stand would
we get a federal claw back if we close
that facility or are those funds given
free and there is no potential for a
clawback I personally don't know because
at the time that I was in the house
there was going to be a claw back but I
attended a work session of a division
three a few days ago well last week and
Mr ribson at that time indicated that
there had been a change in the Federal
Regulation so as a practical matter
there would be no clawback at all but I
think you need to verify that with Mr
ribson
thank you very much thanks Mr chairman
I hope this is a short question
representative Hall it is thank you
would you please summarize your comments
in a letter to the committee for written
testimony
I'll do my best but your time frame
makes that rather difficult I understand
maybe we can have it added to the folder
okay thank you
all right I'm going to recess this this
uh thank you Mr chairman one hearing
until 1 30. the division three is going
to
um go and work on an amendment during
the interim and maybe we would we will
be back at 1 30. we are recessed in
division in this bill I will first read
uh the blue sheet people that have
signed up Governor Chris sununu is is in
favor and you all have a letter from him
Cassandra Sanchez you heard from her
she's in favor Keith crooning from
Waypoint is in favor those are the three
people I have on that
and we will be in recess on eight on
Senate bill one until 1 30.
now we will open the hearing on Senate
uh House Bill 527 and we'll call on his
representative Horrigan here
we'll call on representative horian to
introduce the bill
good morning thank you Mr chairman
I'm representative Horgan from
Farmington and I submit HP 527 on behalf
of uh constituent The Honorable Mr
Campbell who's with us today
uh in a Mad Dash we
ran over to uh legal services to request
an amendment to this uh to basically
replace what we have here for
clarification
uh looking at the amount of the
expenditures we think that's a little
bit High uh we're narrowing the bill
the 16 beds or less to licenses of
pink guy he's got it thank you
representative Petrie my real secret
name is Wayne it's Wayne Campbell
so now the secret is out
um but I had the opportunity to serve
and then Hampshire legislature with the
chairman Weiler and we had a lot so long
I don't recognize you but I
you know it's scary
I do recognize you and it was 20 years
ago and you haven't changed a bit
congratulations
I'm trying to follow my mother's lead
she looked the same at a hundred as she
did at 70.
I won't ask whether you were 70 then or
70 now
in between
I gotta get this button thing down
hit it once I'm good okay so my name is
uh Wayne Campbell and my sister Ann
and I started a assisted living facility
and I think that's the first thing that
we'll explain is it's licensed just a
504 license and we have a copy of that
license so when I asked representative
Horgan and representative Petrie if they
would sponsor this legislation we put in
assisted living facility up to 16 beds
and that has a very uh important import
that means an 804 license
um in the methodology from Health and
Human Services I think there was a
little miscommunication in that they
included all licensed facilities and
that was not the intent of the
legislation so as a former legislator I
I agree that there's some clarity that's
that's perhaps warranted and that would
be that instead of saying a an assisted
living facility up to 16 beds who just
say a 60 living facility with an 804
Residential Care license and what that
does is really narrow the scope of what
we're talking about today and I don't
mean to put Health and Human Services on
on the spot and I wish I had let them
know ahead of time but I would hope that
in division three or later when you look
at that Amendment they could give you an
updated fiscal note that would address
The Limited number of beds in the state
of New Hampshire and quite honestly I
don't know how many there are but I know
that the 805 license which is more of a
Continuum of Care license more nursing
care are a higher level of
in room services for lack of a better
term it's different
but nonetheless an 804 facility as an
assisted living facility is a
residential care facility provides even
more services in my opinion than an 805
and what I mean is and my sister will
speak to this a little bit more is they
take you to the hairdresser they take
you to activities you're you're getting
assistance with your living you're
getting Med management so all the all
the staff are Med certified you have one
RN instead of necessarily RNs going in
and given the service at the same time
but you really have in my opinion a
higher level of service so again the 804
clarification is important because one
of the notes in the fiscal note is that
oh we don't know how to pay different
rates to different facilities when in
fact when you look at the fiscal note
they pay 58 dollars a night for some
facilities 804s and they pay 95 a night
I'm assuming for 805s or other
facilities so there is a precedent that
you would pay facilities at different
rates and I'm asking you to do that for
a couple of reasons one I'm partners
with my three sisters so anybody who
votes against this they're voting
against my sisters that's not no
you know not a good idea so
um so when we opened this facility it
was right when covet hit it took over a
year to get the approval and I will tell
you there was a a substantial amount of
confusion on the requirements and just
for a visual aid uh Mr chairman
in this packet you have 804 license
administrative rules different than 805
license administrative rules
definitionally they're very similar
requirements are very similar just to
give you one example 805 is NFP 101
where 804 is a different fire Life
Safety Code a little bit less
so there's lots of little nuances like
that I don't want to get into it I just
want to make the point that they are
different levels of almost like a
private school versus a public school
just a different set of rules but
they're both licensed schools different
set of rules they're both licensed care
facilities one is specifically an
assisted living facility and that's what
this bill is about
um that right now for a small facility
to exist in New Hampshire if you get
paid the Medicare rate it's just not
enough because you don't know what
you're going to get in matching Social
Security funds or matching funds from
their retirement if they had one and
this bill not only will help this very
limited number of facilities but I want
to point out it's really going to help
patients in the facility if you end up
and I look around this room no reference
to the earlier comments but if you're
nearing that time frame where you might
be in an assisted living facility you
might want to support this bill because
what this bill would do is if you're not
quite out of you know you're still
driving maybe you can still self-shower
there's rules that that you have to be
able to do to be in one of these
facilities so if you're in that
situation you can only keep 72 dollars a
month
so if it costs 4 500 a month to be in
one of these facilities one of the
cheapest rates in the state
and your Social Security is only seven
hundred dollars
that's not going to even be the average
it's not going to get you to 4 500 so
I'm going to get you close with the
current rate of 59 a month
matter of fact if you increase the rate
to 115 dollars a day it only gets you to
3 200 from the Medicare reimbursement
rate and then you're still going to
probably have to pay on average it's
about eight hundred dollars and when
they accept a client they don't get to
know what their social security is they
don't get to know what their retirement
money might may or may not be so here
they have these people in desperate need
that a lot of times are homeless this
bill will address head on the elderly
homelessness population in a very
positive way by providing beds for these
people that are high functioning enough
that they can almost take care of
themselves but not quite
and when they're faced with the decision
of moving into a facility and know that
the only funds they're going to have
available to them is 72 dollars a month
that's a problem
so if you increase it to 115 someone
who's making more than a thousand
dollars a month in their retirement or
more than a thousand dollars a month in
their social security or whatever those
different levels of income is they'd be
able to keep that money over the
thousand dollars not just the 72 bucks
so this bill is important not just for
the facilities but for this population
try living on 72 dollars a month
I know I'm happy that my mother is a
client in this facility
um and I'm probably not supposed to say
and I give her 200 you know I give her
money because she can't live on 72
dollars a month and if she didn't have
me as her son that's what the state
requires her to do so that's one of the
biggest problems I want to help these
individuals I want to make sure that if
if you understand if you're a person who
doesn't have a payee and we made the
mistake early on we accepted some
clients who didn't have a state payee
okay if you don't have a state payee and
someone's getting a thousand bucks a
month and they're being told they got to
give you 918 of that money good luck
I mean desperate people do desperate
things so then all of a sudden all we're
getting is this reduced Medicare rate
and we have a 72 year old borderline
homeless person in our facility paying a
third of the money they should be paying
it's a problem and it will bankrupt
these smaller facilities and I would say
to you that the data I'd like you to
look at is what where the 804 license
facilities post covid what are the 804
license facility after covid
representative Petrie from Farmington
Horgan from Farmington we have a place
called Hattie's place that was
demolished turned back on they were
trying to get an 804 license three years
ago when we were trying to get the 804
license and the state repeatedly wanted
them to be to an assisted care license
criteria to the 805 or that and they
claimed it was a miscommunication I
would boldly say that the state would
rather have Continuum of Care facilities
and that's fine if that's their policy
change the law right now the law is
licensed for 804 facilities and they
serve a vital and important role for
assisted living and there's a lot of
people that will be in that level of
care for a long period of time the
public policy problem is when they
transition to a nursing home there's a
transition that has to happen that's a
negative I can't disagree with that if
you're in a facility that does every
level of care you can stay in that
facility but you're really not you're
moving to a different section or you
move into a different thing and my last
point that I'll make is that that this
bill favors small businesses
entrepreneurs like us from New Hampshire
it supports the North Country it
supports entrepreneurs opening up small
businesses and instead we have higher
levels of pay for facilities that are
owned by hedge funds or large companies
and I think in New Hampshire being a
small state with a lot of small
businesses being the backbone of our
economy and our employment whenever the
and I know this is a fiscal committee
but whenever there's a an opportunity to
fiscally support small businesses we
should lean heavily in that direction
because it's very important that we have
more of these small businesses because I
hope that's my sister will tell you
briefly I know I talk too much I'm sorry
that we are able to provide a level of
care that you're not going to get in a
hunter bed facility we're able to
provide a level of care that it's her my
sister Elaine in the kitchen my sister
Sharon who's an RN and my mom doing
activities while she's living there it's
a wonderful facility and when we looked
at all the facilities of buying an
existing location I saw a lot of
family-run small businesses that these
people were connected in the lives of
their clients and they and and quite
frankly I'm being asked to subsidize 11
people in uh Charlestown New Hampshire
and I do that because one of them is my
mother but I I if we don't have a
fiscally reasonable payment plan 58
dollars isn't it 115 is a reasonable
plan where maybe the people get to keep
a little bit of their money maybe we can
have a profitable business model and
maybe we can you know not continue to go
into debt but to pay down debt and with
that I'll let my sister answer any
questions that you might have about the
day-to-days of the facility and and how
important this would be to improve the
lives of their clients there
I think I kept track between what you
were talking about monthly payments and
daily payments but you seem to use
monthly for all of them but I have it
all written out and have turned a copy
over to your LBA staff very good
questions from the committee members
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair I for the sake of the question
just assume that everything you said
sounds good to me uh this is strictly a
process question do you do you do you
have somebody in working for a DHHS like
for Henry lippman or somebody we're
we're one we're less than one week away
from having uh the budget provided to us
to start working on and this this is one
issue of multiple issues that we have to
deal with in Medicaid and so rather than
dealing with this as a separate bill I'm
just asking you if you have support in
the department to where we could just
roll this into our budget process and
take a look at all all of the moving
parts and not just one piece at a time
I hope that I have support of the
department I think it's a good idea and
I think but do you know I'm not talking
about Hope unfortunately not being
connected in here every day like you are
I do not have a relationship with DHS
and I don't know what their position is
on the bill but I'd be happy to meet
with them get back to you before the
work session and I'd also just to answer
what I think is your question
representative Edwards if you want to
handle this as part of the budget and
honest a separate bill and I know that
this committee is going to look at those
rate pays for 804 and put it in the
budget however we skin the cat I'm fine
with that as long as we accomplish
getting 804 facilities a reasonable pay
58 isn't it so if you want to put that
in the budget I would welcome that I
don't think that we need a separate bill
I just think we need to accomplish the
additional payment level
thank you for the answer thank you Mr
chair
representative for a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in
two quick questions do you have any idea
how many 804 facilities there are on the
state and how many total beds do they
contain actually what I know is that
seven have closed in the last couple of
years
um those were all small businesses
Hattie's Place horseshoe Pines Freedom
Manor
um it's it's been a steady role of
places not being able to make it
financially between trying to pay their
staff a living wage
um we raised our wage to 15 an hour in
November of 21 and thanks to a state
Grant we're able to maintain that
throughout this year and give our
employees a small you know Christmas
bonus that they really appreciated
but
the 15 an hour in Sullivan County
doesn't get you an apartment on your own
you know if they're not a two income
family in New Hampshire they have a
problem with housing we have lost people
to South Carolina because of the housing
rates in here and pay the wage situation
um so we really really need to be able
to increase our wages increase our staff
right now we're running at nine beds
because adding two more people in which
we'd love to do puts us at a staffing
level that we can't support
um the 515 an hour would allow us to add
two more Medicaid beds would allow us to
add staff to
apply that support we do have people
that as mentioned shower
independently still drive their cars but
we also have people that are full help
they don't get their socks on by
themselves
we use both the underserved senior adult
population and we have mental health
members in our facility we used the
program that the state ran two years ago
for moving elderly patients from New
Hampshire hospital and Glencliff into
appropriate Assisted Living prop
population house homes so that they
could have the least restrictive
environment one of them it's worked out
beautifully Another one not so much
but we're struggling along with her and
that bonus that was given to us and the
pay rate that was given to us for that
year were both godsends that program did
a great support for us it's over now and
we're back to trying to live on our
budget and 58.66 a day is a budget
number that
is really difficult to support
um it is 74 by the way but they get to
keep but that's not enough to buy our
One smoker a carton of cigarettes on any
given month
um we end up supplementing his smoking
habit but you know we like to keep him
happy oops outside did we just testify
we encourage smoking in the elderly yeah
yeah he's been smoking for 60 years 60
years the chances of our breaking it
aren't good we do get him routine chest
x-rays and make sure he's not doing any
damage so far so good he'll be 80 in a
year
you know it's not a point that we're
going to take away from him at this
point we because we're a small facility
we can individualize the person that
likes to go to museums can go to museums
the people that like to go to the Animal
Farm can go to the Animal Farm we want
to support their individual growth their
activities of daily living and their
enjoyment of life
excellent uh representative I'll take a
crack at answering your question I did
go over with representative Horgan to
um legislative research and I asked them
specifically how many 804 facilities we
have how many beds we have in it and I
asked them how many 805 facilities we
had and how many beds we had in it so
the committee would be able to see the
difference in the type of facilities
that are out there but I think Ann did
an excellent job of saying we know of
seven facilities that have closed as a
result of the disparity in the payment
system from the state and if if they're
getting 95 a day I think we should get
20 more because we provide more services
do you have that number yeah uh the
research has not provided that to me yet
but I think we can have it by your work
session this afternoon
thank you follow up from representative
representative
excuse me
Papa Vichy Miller thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking the question
I heard your testimony that basically
the you know lower investment rate is a
continuous Financial challenge but you
mentioned a lot of closings during the
last couple of years and we are all very
aware of the huge impact that was added
by covid and all those challenges
can you get us an idea of you know were
those businesses that may have been
maybe barely viable without kovid and
kovid put them under or is this you know
have you seen stuff like this happening
before covet hit I I just need to you
know understand a little bit how to
separate those two if you can offer any
information to that I know it's a
complicated question it is complicated
and covet hasn't helped because it has
decreased our available Staffing and
that has been an ongoing problem for all
804s because they make less money they
pay less wages but covet wasn't
necessarily the death now of any of
those places aging out and not having
people to take over the business uh you
know the ownership aging out
um these were all small family-run
operations privately owned they weren't
conglomerates like some of the other
places some of the larger places are
they were small business owners and
without the support of the state they
were running on too thin and Edge to
survive covet and at the 58.60 cents
point mark
it's incredible I mean we are one of the
more reasonably priced assisted livings
in the area has told to me by members
that have been looking for housing we do
take patients with challenges that are
slightly Beyond 804 level of care in
only because we have staff capable of
supporting those members with their
mental health needs we do a lot of
transportation
and most places don't they use the
transportation service companies which
our members aren't capable of doing on
their own I mean it's like putting your
mother in a taxi cab to Boston you
wouldn't do that
definitely not my late mother was in
Romania but no seriously I really want
to thank you for a very insightful
answer and for sharing your perspective
I find it very very valuable because you
know I'm a freshman I'm learning a lot
so thank you for contributing to that
thanks
further questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman representative
Stringham I want to make sure I
understand your bill as amended
um the uh as revised the special rate
would would apply only to 804 registered
and also be restricted to those who have
a greater than 50 percent
Medicaid occupancy so in your case if
you have you have I think 11 beds in um
in your facility if five or fewer of
them were Medicaid uh as proposed it
would revert to the existing rate
um and just just to kind of get an idea
if if instead of uh providing this in
terms of an increased uh per diem rate
if it was just a straight Grant if
you're looking at uh uh six people a day
for it for a year and an extra 60 bucks
it's about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year for year one facility
do those numbers are they in line with
um kind of what you're you're here
asking for today yes sir
um the 50 Mark is to try and encourage
additional Medicaid bed rates because
right now
the Medicaid bed rate of some of the
privately owned facilities can be
anywhere from 10 to zero they have a
choice they don't have to take
especially private facilities don't have
to take a Medicaid bed rate if they
don't have a bed available at the time
and I want to encourage those kind of
places the the
804 section of a larger Continuum home
first per se
to take that 50 of Medicaid bed rates
just to get
some of the
seniors that are living in homeless
shelters that comes automatically to
mind because we're taking someone from a
homeless shelter this week
um
because the encouragement of and the
opportunity for small business owners to
open more of these facilities is there
and is viable at 115 a night
I'd like to take a crack at answering
that
um that is definitely the original
intent of the bill was that you'd have
this critical level I would submit to
the committee that if you're going to
look at the amendment that we're
writting writing I did simplify it to
just be an 804 facility the original
reason I said 50 is because these bigger
facilities can have one or two Medicare
beds and I didn't know if there was a
requirement for them to do that and
they're able to average that lower cost
out over 100 beds so originally the 50
was the idea that if you're a small
facility it's kind of like if you're a
private care facility and you're
charging nine thousand dollars a month
it's just a different facility that's
charging forty five hundred dollars a
month it's just a different type of
arrangement and that social economic
payment class usually doesn't mix but I
would say to you that if you're going to
narrow it with the amendment I I believe
the bill only addressed 804 facilities
because it said assisted living
facilities up to 16 Beds which is
definitionally what a NATO force
facility is so I don't think there's any
change in what the intent or what we
filed it just makes it clarify that it's
an 804 and in the amendment the way we
drafted it it left out the 50 stuff and
again we live in this fluid world so
it's like what's better the 50 criteria
or if you pay 804 facilities that accept
a Medicare bed and they said well I
wasn't going to accept any but if I get
this right I'll accept one or two or
three I would say to you that that might
be better than the 50 criteria I don't
know which which would drive up more
beds and I would say to you that if you
limit it to 804 it eliminates the huge
fiscal impact and I would submit to you
that if you pass this bill that the
fiscal impact is so minor it's not going
to throw off the whole state budget or
perhaps even be anything that we'd have
to really consider us a big issue in the
budget because it's limited to the 804
and then if it's limited to whether it's
one bed or fifty percent of the beds it
wouldn't make a big difference But to
answer your question five beds a year I
think that 150 number sounds about right
to what the impact would be on an
individual facility that had six
Medicare beds and that's the difference
between us you know losing 50 Grand a
year and maybe you know for the four
Partners oh my gosh they might make 20
grand for the the economic risk and what
we did this is not it is a money making
proposition and I believe in the
for-profit business but my sisters are
Saints they're Saints with what they do
every day
um I was a landlord for 25 years I can't
imagine the level of care that they're
giving these individuals and I mean to
go up there and have a drunk 72 year old
man
assaulting your sister
and having to deal with that
they deserve this 115 a day
we um would also like to mention that uh
my brother God bless them is using
Medicare and Medicare Cade
interchangeably this is a Medicaid Bill
Medicare does not cover 804 facilities
at in any way shape or form our clients
do have Medicare to pay for their doctor
bills the majority of them have Medicaid
to cover the cost that Medicare doesn't
cover but Medicare will not pay for 804.
but just it's interchangeable that's why
she's my older sister
for the questions from committee members
saying none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much good to see you
again good to see you and that
represents that amendment should be
automatically sent to the committee from
legislative Services
um so you should see that sometime today
thank you thank you
all right I'll next call on uh Gary R
Cannon
nharch which he will tell us what that
stands for
it's Gary cohoon
and NH Arch very cool okay the New
Hampshire Association of Residential
Care Homes
which is the state excuse me which is
the Statewide
um Organization for residential care and
assisted living homes
thank you yeah uh and I'm sorry I like
Alex katrubis to join me if I may have
him do that all right we've got cards on
both of you that's fine okay
Alex is New Hampshire artist lobbyist uh
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh I'm handing out a list of
all of the 804 and 805 facilities which
is a question that's come up uh we are
here uh in support of the bill however
we were not consulted or involved with
the drafting uh we represent New
Hampshire Arts which is the assisted
living facility Assisted Living Care
Facility Association in the state I did
reach out to the sponsor to try and
coordinate I wasn't terribly successful
uh but right now there are as you can
see on the final page of the spreadsheet
that Mr Ripple is handing out currently
there's
6534 licensed beds for assisted living
in the state of New Hampshire 65 34.
that comes it's right on the Department
of Health and Human Services website we
don't have to go to house research it's
it's right there on the web for everyone
to see
of those 65 34 beds only 500 of them are
Medicaid beds and that information comes
from the Department dashboard that's
presented to the fiscal committee
generally every fiscal committee meeting
so 606 6500 total beds 500 are Medicaid
beds eligible for reimbursement under
the CFI program I know that you're
really behind on the uh the timing here
so Mr Cahoon is a former owner operator
of Friendship Manor and new web switch
he's an expert on assisted living in the
CFI program he has Decades of experience
so I'm just going to suspend uh thank
the sponsor for bringing it forward but
again we didn't have anything to do with
the drafting or the coordination and I
think that might have uh solved some of
the issues that you've talked about this
morning and I just want to finally say
that I completely agree with
representative Edwards we need to look
at all of the Medicaid rates we have
issues with DD substance abuse mental
health uh all of the Medicaid rates need
to be looked at in in this budget not
just assisted living nursing homes
all of the providers are under an
immense Healthcare Workforce crisis
Meals on Wheels I I could go on so we
need to look at it in the budget process
so whether you retain this bill however
you want to go about it procedurally but
we need to look at all the Medicaid
rates going forward so I'll turn it over
to Mr Cohen thank you Mr chair
thank you for the data you're welcome
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to address
you on House Bill 527.
um my wife and I own friendship manner
in New Ipswich New Hampshire for uh 37
years
uh we closed in May of 2022.
largely for Workforce issues okay I if
you to the extent that Workforce issues
were caused by code I suppose covet
might have been a factor but really it
was Workforce we simply could not hire
enough people to keep going
obviously part of a Workforce Solution
would be an increased rate allowing us
to pay a higher rate of pay to our
employees
it is I will admit it is only part of
the solution there are other demographic
reasons that the workforce is in trouble
um but certainly making rates higher
would help
um before I continue I did hand out some
written testimony there is a typo in it
in the last paragraph I talk about the
cost of building new facilities
and I it says 10 up to upwards of 10
million dollars that actually should be
40 million dollars
so that's a big typo yes all right
um
anyway
um there's no question that an increase
in rates is needed uh and essentially
for two reasons the first is that
there's a tremendous unmet need
and the second reason would be
to save money through cost avoidance
with regard to the unmet unmet need many
of you may be aware that the CFI budget
if you look at that closely you're
somewhat misleading year after year CFI
does not expend All the Monies
appropriated to it
and year after year they don't fill all
this authorized slots for clients that
are that are authorized
by agreement with the federal government
this leads some people to conclude that
this that the CFI need is therefore
being met that is not the case the
reason they can't expend the funds and
fill the slots is that the reimbursement
rates are so low that many providers
providers refuse to participate in the
program
now CFI is the overall umbrella that
covers it's actually the the wafer that
covers Residential Care
with Residential Care the situation is
actually a little bit more complicated
uh it's difficult to determine what the
unmet need in residential care is
compared to the whole CFI program with
the CFI program
we know how many units of service were
authorized to fill the slots that are
that are open but we don't know how many
units excuse me and we do know how many
units were actually provided so the gap
between those two is at least one
indication of what the unmet need might
be unfortunately in residential care
Residential Care isn't authorized for a
client until the client finds a bed
and it's almost impossible to find a Bed
um the
what what appears to be the case if you
look at the numbers is that virtually a
hundred percent of the approved need for
residential care services is met but
that's only that's because of this
technical way in which that's it's it's
uh figured
um friendship manner is was an 804 home
um just to correct one thing that was
said before we were not a 16-bed home we
had 22 beds
804 homes are not limited to
um
16 beds
many of the 804 homes were sheltered
care homes in the past and the sheltered
Care Homes are limited to 25 beds but
they were in fact shelter care homes
that were 100 bits
um
now as as to cost avoidance when
friendship men are closed we were down
to 18 residents we had not admitted
residents for a couple of months because
we knew we might be closing so instead
of the 20 or 21 residents we normally
had we had 18. of those 18 11 were moved
to nursing homes
of those 11. only one of them actually
needed a nursing home bed the other ten
went to nursing homes simply because we
couldn't find a CFI ResCare bed
uh in addition there were seven
residents who went to CFI beds
there are two problems with this the
first is that the state and countyous
are spending much more for a nursing
home bed than they would be for a sea of
ibed and secondly this means that at
least 10 people were denied access to a
nursing home bed who badly needed one
so these are the reasons in a very brief
synopsis why the rates have to increase
there was a question about the number of
homes that had closed obviously
Friendship Manor was one of those and
representative Mueller asked if there
were if homes were closing before the
covert epidemic and in fact there were I
testified in the budget hearings in 2018
about the closure of actually three
homes just before the budget process
um the
Gaffney home in Rochester which had been
in business since 1902 and the carpenter
home in Swansea which was a town owned
home and had been in business since 1937
I believe
and the biggest reason that homes were
closing then and they're closing now is
Workforce homes for the most part have
not been able to hire sufficient staff
and that was certainly true of
friendship manner
in terms of limiting the
increase to 804 homes I would submit
that doesn't really make a lot of sense
uh there are in the list that
um Alex has handed out uh 136 licensed
homes
of those 136 licensed homes only 53 are
are enrolled as Medicaid CFI providers
I'm not sure how many of those 53 are
actually providing Services less than 53
I can tell you that I know that a few
years ago this number was over 80 and
when there were 80 enrolled providers
about 40 were actively providing
services so
uh the 53 homes account for all of the
500 beds that are currently occupied but
it's a relatively small portion of those
homes that are probably accounting for
most of them
um of the 53 homes and again this
statistic had to do with the original
version of the bill only 12. are they
the ones that are shaded
shaded as the Medicaid homes
that accept CFI Medicaid okay I guess
those are the 53 then thank you they're
53 shaded that's right okay
uh so it doesn't really make sense if we
if it's in the public interest uh and
it's good public policy to increase the
utilization of CFI beds and I believe
strongly that that is the case limiting
it to a very small number of the
providers doesn't really make a lot of
sense
um I also would submit that the 50
um required participation doesn't make
sense
um of the
6534 license bed and beds in the state
uh
5192 are in facilities of 50 beds or
greater
most of those larger facilities are new
our new facilities have been built
within the last 10 years or so
and as I said there was a typo in there
I talked about a cost of up to 10
million dollars that was a mistake it's
actually up to 40 million dollars
the majority of those homes if they were
50 medicated anything like the current
Medicaid rate would go bankrupt within a
matter of six months to a year
the the larger newer homes simply cannot
participate fully as it were in the
Medicaid Program but what they can do
and which many of them would be willing
to do is to continue providing services
for people who were there but have run
out of money
Mrs Jones moved into
Happy Valley Assisted Living
six years ago with a couple hundred
thousand dollars in the bank she has now
spent that money
and right now unless the home is willing
to basically give her a free ride she's
probably going to be asked to go to a
nursing home which again might be a very
poor utilization of a nursing home bed
the homes would like to be able to allow
Mrs Jones to start to continue but they
need a somewhat higher rate of pay
actually considerably higher rate of pay
to do so they also need some statutory
and Regulatory changes
um but that's for another time
um the last thing I guess I would say is
I had a conversation yesterday
uh with a lady who was the largest CFI
residential care provider in the state
um she was talking about the increases
in costs in the last year how she's had
to increase her starting salary from
12.50 an hour to 16 an hour how food has
gone constantly up
she altogether has 72 beds three
facilities one of six two of 16 and one
of 40. and what she told me yesterday
was if the current Trend continues for
another year or so I will be getting out
of the business
and my 72 beds will go with me
and that's it thank you for your
patience I will be happy to try any
questions you have
all right I see at least three
representative papavichi Mueller then
representative Edwards and
representative leishman
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions this is more of a request
could we uh get this spreadsheets and to
us in electronic Forum because honestly
you know working off paper is not that
effective and uh you know would
appreciate that absolutely I have it in
Excel and I'd be happy to send it to you
thank you representative Edwards for a
question thank you Mr chair I I we're
going to have substantial conversations
on all of this on Medicaid day in
division three I invite you all to come
in when that's on the calendar uh and
then I'm horrible at your last name I
know Alex is your first name you you you
started to hit multiple different types
of bed rates if you if you could maybe
maybe I already have this information
somewhere but if you if you to the
extent that you're aware of varying bed
rates what they are for how much they
are and when they went into effect last
uh I I'd appreciate having division
three use that as a reference document
absolutely I will prepare that and
presented to division three how can you
do that yeah all right thank you sir the
daily rate for um uh Residential Care is
56.88 I I I I don't want to hear it I
want to I just wanted to make one of it
one of the comment there was a reference
to a 95 rate which is a no you're
talking
805 rate
which is inaccurate there is no 805
right
okay representative leishman for a
question
thank you very much Mr chairman and hope
this question is easy uh are most of
these facilities tax exempt or not for
profit I have no idea what between the
difference between 805 or 804 at least
that to my colleagues on division three
but just curious
many of them are organized as
not-for-profits but not all of them the
smaller homes tend to be for-profit not
that they make one uh Friendship Manor
was a C Corp
um
technically for profit but again we
didn't make one my wife and I can were
able to do that for 37 years because we
didn't depend upon it to live one of us
always worked outside of the manner to
basically support our family
thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman
any further questions from committee
members representative McGuire
thank you I'm also not very familiar
with this is so there are some assisted
living in the state that are not on this
list for example my County I think has
Assisted Living no I'm sorry what I
think my county has an assisted living
facility is that right I mean some
Communists have assisted livings yes
there are three or four
is that it everything else that's
private everything that's private would
be on this list is that yeah
um assisted living is not a licensure
term the licensure term is is
Residential Care
um there is in RSA 161-j a stipulation
that someone who advertises as an
assisted living home must be licensed
but there is no Assisted Living license
so assisted living homes are licensed as
resident either residential care which
is 804 or supported residential care
which is 805.
may I follow up thank you and follow-up
I was going to mention there were two on
here that I recognize when I was on the
board of for a while that was run by the
Masons and the Masons supported it and
the one in Rockingham County the county
supports it so some of these are
supported by others than just the money
that's coming in thank you yeah I looked
for my county and I didn't see it so
anyway
um so
what's the what's the basic difference
between 804 and 805 is it simply 16 beds
or more no 15 or less no because it has
nothing to do with with bed size it has
to do with the the level supposedly with
the Acuity of the population served in
other words
how sick are they how impaired are they
what do they need in terms of nursing
Services it is a very very on
clearly defined in both law and
regulation though
there's a lot of overlap in other words
okay one more tonight thank you
um the the fiscal note implies that
um 804s get get a one rate and 805s get
a different rate but you said that's
incorrect that's incorrect there are
there are two Acuity based rates which
came out of a pilot program and I
believe was in 2002. okay
um it was they were intended largely for
memory care or Alzheimer's care
uh the pilot program was more or less
successful there were three homes that
participated in it one of which no
longer does
the pilot program was continued So
currently there are two homes that
receive those rates but only two homes
they are both 805s but it's not an 805
rate
one of the things our association
recently requested was could we
go back to that concept go back to the
successful pirate pilot and have Acuity
based rates in other words open these
rates up to something more than two
homes out of 136. and that rate's about
eighty dollars there are two rates one
is about 85 the other's about 95. okay
thank you
are the questions from committee members
all right seeing uh now we'll hear the
from the counties and Kate Horgan from
the New Hampshire Association of
counties uh-huh
thank you Mr chairman my name is Kate
Horgan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties which is all of
you are elected and appointed officials
at County government level uh the
association does not have a formal
position on this bill but to answer
representative McGuire's question there
are three counties that also have an
assisted living facility they are
Rockingham Merrimack and Cheshire county
um the association would ask that if you
are to consider this to please do it for
all rates doing it for a small subset
doesn't make sense all facilities are
facing Workforce shortages small margins
all of you are members of your county
delegations you know your nursing homes
operated a deficit every single year so
we would just ask that you if you're
going to increasing rates you increase
them for everyone and not a small subset
I'm happy to take any questions that the
committee has
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming what is
the total number of beds in these three
facilities uh I would have to get back
to you on that representative McGuire
but I can certainly get that number for
you
representative Heath thank you
um thank you for taking my question do
you have any idea what the waiting list
is Statewide for nursing homes I can Mt
nursing homes thank you for the question
representative I can speak to the
counties uh for the nursing homes uh I
would the average is over a hundred
people for every single County right now
some counties are have more I know
Cheshire county for example I think is
at 120 right now and they just had to
close an entire Wing because they cannot
staff that wing
thank you
um
I
I'm I had a meeting with Jason Smith who
is managing the Rockingham County homes
and uh
a lot of what we talked about were
exactly those challenges about you know
the rage being so low it makes it really
hard for them to be able to pay the
wages that would allow them to retain
the staff and that's where all the
workforce but you know issues are
starting
does your Association have you know its
own guideline I mean this this is a bill
proposed but do you have any uh
you know broad position from your
associations in terms of what the rate
should be and if so could you provide
that those suggestions to us we do not
we are actually working on that Senator
Rosenwald actually has a bill that would
raise all Medicaid rates uh for all all
Medicaid rates across the board and we
are in the process of figuring out what
those numbers should be I believe it's
Senate bill 86.
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much we will
close the hearing on Senate on House
Bill 527 and is there a list
a blue sheet
yep it's coming
oh we got one person wants to speak
identify yourself please thank you
uh good afternoon Mr chairman my name is
Rob Berry I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services I thought I
submitted a pink card apparently didn't
get to you I apologize for that
um to my right I have Miss Christie Roy
and she can explain what she does for
the Department
I'm Christy Roy and for the Department I
work in the rate setting area for DHHS
so we wanted to just provide a little
bit of information prior to the work
session we don't have a formal position
on the spill either but we did want to
give a little insight as to how we got
to our fiscal analysis so the department
does not believe it's permissible to
Target rates as is contemplated by this
legislation that being the size of a
facility and the Medicaid utilization
rate we base our rates on the Acuity
level of individuals within the assisted
living facilities so we have currently
three different rates the lowest one
being the 58 and change in the highest
one being somewhere around
it's 95 41 currently 41. um so we're
happy to work last one again
95 41 so there are two dementia level
rates so there's the standard
Residential Care rate for CFI which is
our choice for Independence which is the
56.88
the second rate is dementia level one
which is 84.74 and the third rate is for
dementia care level two which is 95.41
they're service based rates we don't
have a facility specific rate model for
this so that's where the challenge comes
in
um it's a service level rate so that's
where the Acuity would be it's
additional Acuity Services needed for
those additional dementia levels
thank you
questions from the committee members
representative Edwards then
representative McGuire I thank hey thank
you to the department for coming to this
I uh I look forward to doing a deep dive
on all of this in in uh in division
three and you heard me ask Alex a little
while ago if he's got a sheet on all the
different categories of uh of bed rates
and when they were established and how
much they are I I think if we had a
comprehensive document to look at that
would help us go through and figure out
what we want to do to the big picture
and not just one-offs sure and now we're
trying to also have somebody from
licensing uh come to the work session as
well to explain the differences between
hee 804 and 805 if that would help the
committee as well all right and you know
the way that works Mr Ripple schedules
with Nathan white and then you guys get
alerted okay all right thank you
representative McGuire real quick thank
you Mr chairman thank you for coming so
we heard earlier that um a total of 535
beds are receiving these rate these
three rates I guess is that true or is
there there more that's likely go ahead
the for so for State fiscal year 22 the
total days that I had pulled from our
mmis system which is our Medicaid
management information system was just
under 200 000.
total days
I'm gonna have to get my calculator
representative Prophet popovichi Mueller
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and answering questions I
mean you've been here when we were
hearing the testimony about the impact
of the uh you know lower rates uh to you
know the ability of the centers to
provide service obviously that testimony
is you know narrow in the sense that it
reflects their experience for you as the
department could you provide any color
or information to us in terms of whether
the current rates allow for the centers
to sustainably operate or is there a
concern at the department level over
these Trends I just would like to hear
your thoughts on this
I believe we'd have to get back to you
on that we have to speak to some people
at the department to get their views on
it
um that's more of a finance three
question anyway but I thought while we
were here you know if you could share
something with Elsa certainly
representative Petrie
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
being here uh has these closings around
the state has that put you know
additional uh pressure on these you know
on finding beds
so I can't speak to that personally
um I will try to get something from
licensing here but I can say that I
would expect that that would put
additional pressure on
um on facilities and individuals who are
looking for beds to have fewer available
foreign
Stringham
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
the rates on
um
you mentioned that the the rates paid
vary by the Acuity is there anything in
the uh fee schedule that incorporates
things like local wage index Indigent
care factors or Capital issues or
anything that would affect that and
could you also comment on uh what you
what restricts you from incorporating a
percent Medicaid as a factor in setting
the rate
I'm going to differ to Christy in that
um so again it's a service-based rate
they were increased five percent from
hb2 in July they're a CFI rates so any
other CFI legislation would also affect
this rate
um in the rate methodology that was
determined I when it was set there it
was out there was an outsourced company
I believe that worked with the
Department to come up with those
original rates and then my understanding
in the waivers there's uh information
about updating annually based on the CMS
Market Basket for CFI rates and then
they are additionally
held to a budget adjustment factor or a
budget neutrality Factor so there's
plenty of complexities in that rate
methodology
that you can add to
it
quick follow-up
how many facilities uh have have waivers
on on the base rate uh I thought you
said some do
waivers on the base rate meaning
waiver so they have an adjustment
so
um
the adjustment is service level based so
it would depend on the qualifications
within that service or the the need of
this what's required for the service
it's not a facility specific adjustment
so if there are only two facilities that
would provide that additional level of
service or that additional level of care
and what's required for that additional
level care there are two facilities but
there's no limitation to the quantity of
facilities that could provide that
additional level of care if they so
choose they just have to I would assume
apply for and prove that that's the
additional level of care they're
providing for that service
foreign
representative Edwards for a question
thank you Mr chair this could just be a
really short answer uh the five percent
that you mentioned in hb2 it's my
understanding that that expires at the
end of this hb2 period and and rolls
back to the previous level unless
reauthorized in the next hb2 or or or is
that was that a permanent increase to
the Baseline
going forward
my understanding is it's permanent but I
can we can look into that for you yeah
thank you
historically adjustments to rates when
you're reducing it you have to prove
that it's not affecting access to care
for Medicaid so if there is an
adjustment to that rate a decrease it
would be a significant lift to prove
access to care especially with what
we're hearing today
further questions from committee members
seeing none we did find your card sorry
we lost it that's all right
anybody else that wishes to make
comments on
House Bill 527
seeing none I have on the blue sheet
just the two Campbells that have signed
in and and pro both Ann Campbell and
Campbell uh no other signatures on
there
thank you all I'm going to close this
hearing on House Bill 527 you'll be
hearing more from division three when it
will be scheduled for probably
continued on with all the other Medicaid
rate discussion
thank you all for your testimony thank
you all for coming
I'll close this hearing
so with that I'd like to open division
three uh where I'm going to meet
immediately put us into recess uh until
uh say 12 35 so that should give people
time to go get something to eat and come
back we'll be in here at 12 35 to deal
with three bills
we're in recess
all right uh we were supposed to start
at 12 35 it's uh 12 50 15 minutes late
uh that's on me uh we're out of recess
uh we're uh here in a division three
work session
um on the calendar is to discuss House
Bill 49 that we've had in division three
for a little while House Bill 527 that
we just uh talked about in full Finance
today and could talk about it a little
bit today and the uh the star attraction
of today is uh is sb1
so
um
I'm going to start with
I think I think to get a sense of where
we're at uh I I'd like to get a straw
vote uh I have been a supporter of sb1
um from the beginning we're going to
take that up first I think sb1 and uh
and I I would like us I would like
everyone to tell us through a straw vote
where they think they are on sb1 and
then we can talk about an amendment to
sb1 that's the same thing as the
amendment to 49. so so those
conversations will converge but to
establish a baseline I think we need to
make sure that there's absolute Clarity
on where people are with sb1 so so I
would I would take a motion to um
on OTP of sb1
now where it's going to be it's not a
real vote I'm taking a straw I want to
make sure I know where people are at I
think I think the public needs to know
where people are at on this
okay so Mr chairman subject to our
conversations of yesterday it seems like
we're formulating a good Amendment so I
would make the motion to ought to pass
on Senate bill one okay is there a
second
second okay
um so uh is there the discussion on this
is that the Senate passed sb1 24 to
nothing
um this was an enormous high water mark
in the past decade where people have
often said that we needed to do
something to replace the sununu center
and the desire to do something
reached kind of a boiling point two
years ago when the legislature
passed into law the closure of the
sununu center on one March of this year
that's just a few weeks from now
the legislature had an opportunity to
pass a committee conference report and
did not
the reason the committee conference
report failed it was really I think
predominantly a burnt around capacity
there was there were different views on
what the capacity ought to be there was
a position that went with the house
representatives of six the senate had a
vision of 12 with a flexibility of up to
and when that topic came up the
conversations broke down and the
committee conference uh
broke up and didn't didn't complete any
work
so here we are nobody introduced
anything last year to fix this problem
we creep into this year
now about to begin our budget cycle with
the sununu Center closing in a few days
and the legislature still has not acted
so sb1 is half of the legislature acting
strongly and convincingly with a 24 to
nothing vote
it's hard to beat 24 to nothing in the
Senate that bill came over to the house
for us to consider the house has looked
at this issue in multiple different ways
children and family law saw a similar
bill with House Bill 120 in which
division three was invited to that
then we had House Bill 49 where we've
gone through a lot of discussion deep in
discussion on amendments it started with
the Waller Amendment and then division
three came to a significant agreement
yesterday and and so we've got that and
so we are on the cusp of success in
doing our job and and so what I think a
vote on sb1 will do
will be to bring us to concur with all
of the hard work of the Senate that's
been done and supported by the
department
that's been done and supported by the
advocacy group and the public that's
been done and supported and we have a
letter from the governor
so out of respect for all of those
people
that have looked at this and have
delivered us sb1
I would like us to vote do we think yes
or no we can support sb1 or not
so this is not a formal vote this is a
sense of the committee
um is there any further discussion
uh yes representative hole
thank you chairman
um I think yesterday in division three
we had a very productive session talked
about a a number of things
somehow along the way we ended up with
this deadline of March 1st
that in some ways is an artificially
driven deadline by prior law
it's not like the building stops working
on on March 2nd
the
the goal of of kind of figuring out what
you want to do before you go do it is an
important thing to me as an engineer and
what I see now is we're trying to create
and spend money but we haven't defined
the location or what the facility is
before we even get there we're saying go
spend right 15 million dollars so
um
uh hearing what you said there's a lot
of people that say this is a good idea
and it did pass out of the Senate 24-0
but I think we're not quite ready there
so
um as is amended by the Senate and
passed by the Senate I can't support it
okay I I I respect your conclusion I
just I just want to bring some facts
that we've heard in testimony and that
that the we heard that the 15 million
dollars that found its home in sb1 was
the original estimate
um that we that came about as a result
of there being a special committee on
the sununu replacement Center uh and
that what we have experienced in the
past year or so of of delay is a very
strong inflationary problem with with
supply chain issues and that and that
delay in this case probably contributed
from going from a 15 million dollar
estimate to a 21.6 million dollar
estimate and I don't know what another
delay would do if if this is still a
good idea at the end of the day does it
become a 25 million dollar good idea or
not I I I do think we've been given some
some numbers and I can understand that
we've had bizarre inflation and the
United States over the last two years so
so that that attributes the distinction
between the 15 and the 21.6 I'm not I'm
not saying that to change your mind I'm
just making sure that the record's
complete right thank you
um
so I agree and this goes back to I think
yesterday in our committee or
division we had a a great work session
to work out some of these issues
um I'm going to bring come to page four
lines 30 and 31.
quote in no event shall the total
expenditures from all sources for the
design and construction of the new
secured Youth Development facility
exceed 15 million dollars end quote
right that is in severe conflict to
right and that bill was drafted this
year we're not talking about something
from two years ago the Senate could have
in their in their due diligence put in a
number that was more representative of
the cost of a facility
that's on top of where is it and whether
it's for 6 to 12 or 12 to 18 and I think
our amendment that was proposed
yesterday to start looking at some of
those issues was critical that's why I'm
having trouble with what was passed out
of the Senate
all right thank you representative
Stringham you have anything to add to
the discussion
um well I'm against sb1 as written given
our lengthy discussions yesterday and uh
the direction we were taking things
uh thank you uh representative Weiler
we have to pass something we're two
years behind there's a date coming up
within days
we can't just say we're going to kill
this and start over again there isn't
enough time next week we're going to get
the budget and we're going to be buried
in it we got to do something now today
to move this along if we pass sb1 even
if this thing's in it you don't like
the most important thing in it we've
moved the date out
then when we get to the spending and the
rest of it
we're going to
be able to adjust that within the budget
process and put it in hb2 if need be any
amendments to it that we decide needs to
be in there but we've got to pass
something to move the date away from
March 1st so I I wasn't clear I I'm
proud this is probably not exactly the
way the parliamentarian would run this
but we're talking about sb1 I still
intend to have us discuss the Division
III amendment that we came to agreement
on last night so so so I I want to see
where we are on sb1 before we begin to
entertain The Division III Amendment and
to find out if anyone else has brought
an amendment forward for us so
um all right so uh representative
Wallner
I would I would not
um support Senate bill one as it's uh
before us right now I would um take a
look I want to take a look at
um amendments to it and um I'm really
concerned that we still do not know the
location of this facility and I think
that that's one of the first things we
need to do is try to figure out where it
is going to be
and work with the communities and then
move forward from there and I think in
the budget is the place that we need to
be looking at the financial aspects of
this I would I would support
um the department has testified number
of times that they need additional funds
to get through this biennium and I would
support
um
allocation of additional funds for them
uh thank you for that discussion
representative tolerski
thank you Mr chairman
um sb1 is written I think as a division
we've pinpointed some problems with and
i would support discussion of the
Amendments that we have reviewed in the
past few days
uh thank you representative nordgren
I agree with Mary Jane and Laura
representative Mooney
certainly we did spend a great session
as representative hole said on amending
it so I think to move forward I would
suggest voting ought to pass on the bill
and then take up the Amendments if
that's in order
all right so I think we just took a
Strava while we got the discussion I I
recorded in my head is three yay OTP 5
nay on passing sb1 or recommending a
passage out of division three does
anyone want to have me go around and do
a more formal Vote or would you accept
that it's probably three five
oh okay so
um thank you let's transition uh Mr
Ripple have you laid out the the current
amendment that we worked on last night
all right thank you
uh actually there was another change the
Dinky Dinky little typo
that uh that has since been fixed since
you
had an email
Mr chairman was the issue of Quorum
addressed in that typo
there was a question raised regarding
yeah we can talk about that but but the
short answer is yes we we we we we we
changed the numbers of representatives
from the local community from three to
just being representatives to let the
commission find its right size and then
without a clear number of how many would
be on the commission we we made it a
majority of those appointed to the
commission so so I think that resolved
that issue and what we just talked about
is on we're jumping around a little bit
but since you brought it up on page two
line
15 and line 16 a version that you saw
last night said three representatives
and instead of saying three
Representatives we made it generically
representatives and and that was so that
we didn't waste motion we've we've heard
that there are three potential places we
could go
one of them doesn't sound like a it's
going to pass the common sense test so
why delay the commission looking for
somebody to sit on the board that's
irrelevant so so that's that's what that
that's why that got changed and then
um the other little typo
from what you saw last night is on line
34.
relative to a commission
to study Community impacts uh that that
phrase is consistent with the way we
describe the commission and the
amendment and and last night had the
previous title committee to study Public
Safety so it's just internally making
the document internally compatible
there's no change
so
um
so we're looking at Amendment zero four
five four Hotel
um it basically on step nine I think
we're unanimous that we want
um the the repeal of the closure date
um
I haven't heard any disagreement today
about the appropriation of 1.5 million
dollars so that they can continue
operations through the balance of the
year that's four months of operating
expense anything that they don't spend
would end up getting lapsed back anyways
so is there any discussion or we are we
okay everyone's okay with that
appropriation
okay so now we're down to line 15.
there's now some contention on what was
uh birthed in the walner amendment which
was uh putting aside the sum of two
million dollars uh so that they could
begin the department could begin to
acquire services for site evaluation
everyone says we need site evaluation so
there's site evaluation and that two
million dollars
architect consultation and development
of design options for any replacement
facility we went on to say that we want
two options considered we want an option
for six to twelve and we wanted an
option of 12 to 18. so that's that's
that's in this version of the amendment
that didn't come in initially but we
added it in our conversations and
agreements last night
um Department shall present its
recommended site for the facility no
later than the 30th of September I know
that there's a lot of pressure to do it
sooner than that I think if we just
listen to what's in the wind it's
already been determined where it's
probably going to be and
I I I I I I I I I I don't understand
that being as contentious as it has
become But but so be it
line 22 the appropriation contained in
the section shall not lapse in June of
25 this is different than the operations
money this is the
architect money and then the governor
can draw a warrant
so that is what is in line 15. the first
things first
is this consistent with what you think
we said last night this is a different
question than whether or not you still
support it today the first thing is is
this accurate
is anyone disputing the accuracy of what
we did
okay so so
um I I will say that I support
this from the walner amendment because
it makes sense you you on a critical
path we want a new facility so that we
can transition to a fully therapeutic
model that's in the benefit of best
interests of the kids best interests of
New Hampshire
and on the critical path
these Services site selection
is kind of the first step and I'm
hearing people say we got to do side
evaluation but we don't need to
appropriate the money to do site
evaluation we just need to do site
evaluation and so this is a do Loop in
the software world that just has me
boggled
so this is this is let's one step at a
time let's go do the side evaluation
let's go appropriate the money
so that was my discussion of lines 25
through 31.
are there other points of view we'd love
to hear other points of view
thank you
representative walner
well when I got home last night and
um I started reading this
I always went back to it feels like
we're putting the cart
maybe the whole train before the horse
it's just we need I think someone needs
to make a decision about the site
and I think one of the best ways to make
that decision is for the Department to
say where they think they would be
most in favor of being co-located
because they say that there's a lot of
there's a lot of efficiencies there's a
lot of things to be gained by one site
over another
and so I think that would be the first
thing
that needs to happen is deciding where
it's going to be and then the next part
of that is working with the commission
around that which is made up of people
from the the communities
and start working with them around
um the kinds of things that you think
the community needs to have available
needs to know about the um about the
program before we move into
architectural drawings
design all of those other things let's
decide where it is the sooner we do that
I think the better equipped we will be
to move forward and I also think that a
lot of this is really budget work
because there are
um still
sums of money that need to be
appropriated in the budget
so so the clerk for clarification would
you strike that entire paragraph or
would you perhaps reduce the amount of
money appropriated and limit the work
simply to site evaluation because we've
not technically done a site evaluation
which is the normal first step in
project management before you select a
site so so would you preserve the
paragraph and limit it so that we put
some money into site selection
what I would do is I would direct the
department to
make the best choice from programmatic
reasons
which site they prefer
and I don't think that would necessarily
need
financial support
if they were do that today would that be
dispositive in your view I mean it seems
to me like we would need something
formal from the commissioner or somebody
you I think we already know they want
Hamstead everyone wants Hampstead and
but the problem is if you live in
Hampstead
you have not been respected yet we
haven't gone to Hampstead to say hey
this is what we're thinking what what's
it going to involve well so what what
this amendment does is say okay here's
some money here's the commission go
forward and start working with the
various communities we we can't show up
and say in my view we've already decided
it's going to be in Hampstead now you
tell us why that's not a good idea
that's that's not the way this should
work this should be us coming to them
saying hey look we're looking at three
Alternatives and and this one's got
these advantages these ones got those
discipline advantages and You by God you
are just right you know uh so so I I
think I think you're asking we keep
talking about process I think you your
approach breaks a normal process we
should do site evaluation and work
respectfully with the three communities
before we stick a pin in the na in the
map and say this is where it shall be
deal with it
which which is my really rough
translation of what I'm hearing you say
representative and I apologize that was
that was rude I don't mean it to be rude
uh after two years I'm getting a little
surly
this I would have the department this is
me talking I would have the department
say where it is they feel is the best
location for this facility
from a standpoint of what is going to
meet the needs of the kids the families
and to start that conversation now with
the community
and there's no reason to be speaking to
me there's no reason to be speaking with
three different communities all at the
same time when the department you may be
right the department may already know
where they want to go and now is the
time to start talking with that
community and start really understanding
what this involves
so Mr rips and I think I think we've
heard a lot from you and and picked up
on your reluctance to just answer the
question point blank is is this your is
this your supervisor your manager your
director your your assistant
commissioner in the audience
because I'd love to hear from you I
would like to hear from the person
highest in the food chain on this
because I I think poor Mr ribson is
being put in a highly awkward spot where
he doesn't have the authority to say
that it's going to be in Hampstead and
and if I were Mr Williams I'd advise him
not to say that if it is his friend I
would say I I don't think you should
answer that question but you you you are
a leader you you get paid The Big Box
come on up and tell us what you think
really think about Hampstead please I'll
do all due respect I think I think I'm
I'm a leader too and um and uh
to be fair right
there as I've shared there are three
possible sites that are being considered
I think it was pretty clear when we
spoke yesterday of the three possible
sites which one has the most is the most
advantageous and that is Hampstead but
until we actually do the work to do site
evaluation determine if that's even
feasible for us to say that that's the
site would be irresponsible
right so that's I I don't think we can
give you the solid answer you won until
the work is done to see and even then
that might not be the final decision
because right the department also is not
the final decider on these things right
you work in an executive branch that has
a governor and executive Council so you
know the opinion that I express is not
necessarily what the final decision is
so you know I I understand frustration
and wanting an answer but at the same
time you know if I give you an answer it
it's an answer that I don't actually
have the ability to provide
and an answer that was an Army guy who
trained Afghans how to shoot we we
taught them ready aim fire we didn't
teach them ready fire aim and that's
what I I think I'm hearing is we want to
just say okay we're ready go ahead and
fire we're going to go to Hampstead and
then later we'll keep figuring out
that's going to be the aiming I don't
want to do that I wanted us to get ready
want us to aim at the three sites and
then I want us to pull the trigger on
the correct site there's a discipline
process here I'd love to follow it and
Madam Deputy Commissioner would you read
your name and I'll I'll concur with with
Joe and I think there are many you know
considerations that need to be put into
this I think Joe presented yesterday to
your committee on some of the shared
saving possibilities
um Joe and I work closely with Hampstead
Hospital but there may be other
considerations as well so we really are
not in a position nor is it our role to
be um to be stating what the site should
be so we can't get there today
okay I I hope the media is fair with you
we've asked you to step into a very
awkward situation and I apologize and I
hope you're treated fairly
representative Norton and then
representative Poole thank you Mr chair
um I
I just like your comments on
to Senate bill
we'll start today and I just was
wondering if you had any comments about
it
so
um in general right I still support
Senate bill one I think that the work
has been done to know where we need to
move this
um yes there's some questions that
aren't going to be answered until we
move through the process and you know
honestly I'd
I'd wish that's what I think is the
right path forward
the amendment you know there's some very
critical things that have to happen
right now the most critical thing that
has to happen right now is that the
facility doesn't close in three weeks
that absolutely needs to happen
hopefully by the end of the day today
that there's agreement on that
um and that there's movement on that I
would like us to move forward with the
rest of the package but that's the
absolutely critical point
you have a follow-up
I represent a whole
thank you Mr chair
coming at this from a technical
background and thinking about process
right there's three options that are
currently in play I'm not aware of any
others no one has discussed any others
but typically you rank them relative to
one another
one another over a number of criteria
when can the department have that
information to us
I I think I've already kind of assessed
for everybody yesterday what what the
Departments
position is on that
right so
all of them so
um part of this also is getting some
feedback from the various communities
that are in play right so it's more than
just correct what the how the department
sees it one of the criteria on this list
by which we will be making the decision
right is how the community feels what
the impact of the community will be in
terms of Public Services a bunch of
other things that were discussed
yesterday in our division
I'm used to seeing this as something
called the Pew chart p-u-g-h which is a
process by which you do this you rank
your options on one to axis and you rank
the criteria by which you're going to
score those options on the other axis
and then you just do do the analysis and
go through this I would personally like
to see that as soon as possible I don't
know how quickly we can do that that
might involve having a meeting over in
Hampstead might have a meeting in
Concord somewhere to find and get some
feedback that may take a couple of days
I hear you that we can't we need to
address the issue of closure right away
got it that's which is in my eyes at
least lines nine and following at a
minimum but I would like to see that the
department takes lead
and starts to schedule public feedback
sessions from these communities so we
understand that because that's important
information into making this decision
I'm not sure if that was a question or
not but I guess it's how if that is the
request any idea how long it would take
to schedule that and get back to us I
don't know how long that would take I'd
have to look into that and talk to other
folks so let me ask you about
criticality I I know what the hot urgent
burning issues are the the two we need
more time we need some operations money
got it okay
I'm I'm pretty fired up on the idea that
we have some arpa money out there
that uh we have to hit some milestones
in order to be able to use it I'm not a
gopher expert but you know I think it's
fairly clear that
the longer we wait the more at risk I
can't measure that risk I just think
that that's there that the longer we
wait the more there's risk so so
is it critical that we go ahead and
begin the site evaluation that's in this
paragraph on the two million dollar
appropriation is it critical that we
begin that and fund that now or do you
already have the money and ability to go
ahead and begin that formal Society
evaluation without legislative action we
do not have the resources to do any of
that the process that had been
envisioned working with Das and the
Department of Public Works that that was
going to be built into the contract with
the future you know design firm if
you're talking about carving that out as
a separate process altogether I'd have
to talk to the Department of Public
Works about what that would look like I
couldn't speculate as to what that would
look like so so just to close us I'll
come to your representative Weiler yes
or no do you think the appropriation so
that you can begin the contracted side
evaluation is
urgent is that a critical issue is that
something we ought to be doing like now
or not
I think that if we if the goal is to get
this is right the goal that I've always
understood for the past couple years was
that this needs to get done immediately
right there were timelines put on this
that were incredibly tight and ambitious
under the best of circumstances that's
why we went ahead and started working
with DPW and Architects to try to be
ready to go at the moment that this
legislature said go
if that's no longer the reality then
that's then that then that is what it is
right the
I would I would want to move as much as
possible as soon as possible because I
feel that if we don't actually get to
work on this what I fear is that we're
not gonna ever get this done I sat in
the hearing room downstairs five years
ago listening to you know people
admonish us for not doing this you know
six months after I walked into New
Hampshire for the first time in my life
and you know frankly it's time to get it
done and um so I'd rather do something
than nothing
took so Madam commissioner yes or no is
is the money to begin the site
evaluation critical or not
I do believe it's critical and and part
of what haunts me is Imagining the
staffing issues that are going to
transpire without any serious plan and I
think that is indicative of forward
movement and it's already going to be
hard enough to keep the place um
functioning safely
thank you representative Weiler well
have you been waiting representative
tolersky because I know representative
Weiler is ready do you do you have
something
it's related to what you were saying
which was a clarification for what we
heard yesterday which was
the it sounded to me and I I'm guess I'm
trying to figure out if I'm wrong that
yesterday we heard the department is
moving forward in the process of
determining the best site and you did
not need us to give you that green light
to do it you did not need us to give you
the
part of the two million dollars to get
that done so I guess I'm confused as to
what was just exchanged here no
um I'm not I'm not sure exactly what
what you were calling from yesterday or
if I misspoke but the site evaluation
was always intended to be part of the
contract with the with the external
Architects that piece of the work was
through them making the final
determination around Sight can't be done
until that work is done right and that
work was going to be the first part of
what would be done under that contract
so yesterday I remember talking about
that that would be something that would
probably be from my memory because I
haven't looked at the looked at that
proposal recently would have been done
first and probably in a matter of weeks
to a month or so from the start of that
contract so that would be the first
piece of work done on that contract and
that it would therefore be information
that would be available for the
September 30 date for the committee that
was being discussed yesterday but the
site evaluation work was always a
component of what needed to be done to
make a final decision about a location
we couldn't make a final decision
without doing that work
do you have a follow-up
no all right representative Weiler and
then representative norgren
I've been to all three sites
I was a representative for Hampstead for
20 years before redistricting
I've talked with the representatives
from Hampstead and the senator
who was involved in Senate bill one
um
there's more flexibility on Hampstead
than any other site
that's about 100 acres of woods it's
off the beaten path
it's not on a main road
a lot of people in Hampstead don't even
know it's there it's the hospital that
presently exists
and
we talked about
putting it near the site in Manchester
but it would need another kitchen it
would need somebody to provide meals
that isn't there they don't have a
laundry if they get to Hampstead or
Concord they have shared facilities they
could have meals brought
from another facility as well as laundry
but having sat through the review on the
secure psychiatric facility on Concord I
know the limitations that we've heard
about Concord and there isn't that many
places you could try it in the talk of
wetlands and all that stuff so there's
more flexibility and where it would go
and what can be done in Hampstead as
well as providing adjacent services that
puts it out in the front in my book
and I don't think the Hampstead people
are going to be objective to it for that
small population and that that uh plus
they're getting the property taxes I
think we've got that included that they
would have lost
by the Private Hospital being sold so
I think there's as that was a big a big
stumbling block for Hampstead which has
gone away as far as I'm concerned so
I think that we can we can be certain
that it will end up in Hampstead and
that
you know
they may fine tune it a little more and
pick exactly the site they want at
Hampstead but I think that place has the
most flexibility and is way ahead of the
other sites so I wish we could agree on
this and and get the ball rolling I
don't want to see this happen where
we're always two years behind or maybe
five years behind
um we can't keep kicking the can down
the road let's move and accept this
amendment and pass sb1 and sb49 they're
both the same we can move forward on
this I hate to see all this delays thank
you uh thank you representative Wilder
and uh as as the chair of the committee
let me ask you a question it's getting
close to 1 30 where you said you'd be
pulling us out of recess of the full
Finance it it feels to me like I need
another 20 minutes to be able to give
you a clear recommendation of division
three where we stand on uh this
amendment or any other Amendment get it
done get it done okay thank you sir
representative norgren yeah
to add to the discussion and I yesterday
I was watching online and I was texting
Mary Jane and Laura because I I think we
have to keep considering the employees
of this organization
um I think all the indecision is hard
for them I think we're everyone's having
trouble retaining employees under the
conditions we have now
so I I think we have
urgency for that reason to make a
decision and get things moving so people
who work there know where they're going
know what they're doing have some
stability in their lives so you can hire
more people in fact
so I just wanted to say that thank you
thank you I don't hear a question in
there unless you want to argue with her
uh representative Stringham do you have
yeah just it seems to me that
um you know down to the minutia of what
uh we're we're talking about uh it
sounds like you're gonna you would need
some appropriation uh to go through the
site evaluation process as you described
so moving the number from 2 million to
zero
um uh would uh hamper your progress
somewhat
um so
um uh you know you know if we more
limited and and by the way I trust you
with my life this is this is just you
know I'm just here to represent the
community and and make sure when we ask
them to pay money that that we're
getting something from it so and I thank
you very much for all your testimony
over the last few days
um so
um and you know I don't know which way
we as a group will will go and you know
continue with this larger package are
limited to a site evaluation
but if there's a number less than 2
million and bigger than zero that would
allow you full flexibility to go through
the site evaluation what would that
number be the truth is I don't know the
answer to that question right the two
million all these numbers have come from
the Department of administrative
services and the vision of Public Works
who are the experts and how we build
things and everything else in the state
of New Hampshire and in fact DHHS
where the DPW is the the lead on all
these efforts and we're kind of the
client who is Consulting on on you know
what the needs are around these efforts
so anything I would give would be a
total guess and I really you know
somebody else's guess would probably be
better than mine I I would wag 400 000.
that would be my way just doing projects
in the past but
um all right any other questions on this
because what I'd like to do now is I
want to get a sense of the division on
lines 25 through 31 I'm going to ask two
things
hopefully it'll it only becomes one
thing I would like to know
yes or no do you accept the language
that's already written on Amendment zero
four five four lines 25 through 31 as is
representative Hull
I have no issues with the language I do
ask for a clarification though because
in line 27 we have requests to procure a
qualified architect and then line 28
right which is start the project
immediately I hear that right get the
architect up and running and then in
line 28 I hear a request if you're a
contractor to build and I don't think
that's going in parallel so it's the
same language with two different actions
and I just want to make sure that I
understand or that we somehow document
that this is to get to Define where
we're going but not necessarily go build
and I think I would interpret request to
procure a contractor wanting more of an
RFP right request for proposal process
as opposed to issue a PO but that I just
would like that clarified you know I
think I had stumbled on this before and
we had initially written requests for
proposal and that got changed somewhere
on the along the line and and I think
you've picked up a nice little rub there
that we want to figure out the way it
should lay down I I I I the first one I
think is a request to procure because
all the RFP stuff has been done they're
ready to pull the trigger I believe I
did Mr ribson do you want to tell us if
they're both meant to be requests for
procure and if we do tend to limit if we
decide to limit this do we need to
strike that authorization language so
DPW uses multiple different types of
procurement tools
right and again this is outside of my
scope of expertise but I've learned a
little bit trying to go through this
process and they're not they don't
typically use the request for proposal
tool even though that's the tool that we
typically use in vhhs right so the
reason why we used the language procure
was just to be flexible in the type of
public procurement tool that they would
use to not prescribe which tool is
appropriate that they would use the
request for X whatever that is
um based on their you know expertise in
judgment as the best way to publicly
legally appropriately procure that
service
I I just realized I was on the wrong
section we're still on lines 15 through
24 and I I got myself jumbled oh
so so but that was good foreshadowing uh
represent representative hole would your
concern about the second request for
procure
be satisfied if we ended up striking on
line 17 the phrase architect
consultation and development of design
options
I am okay with that I am okay with what
we agreed to yesterday both both are
options
um if we're going to change the
the effort right then probably the the
amount spent should also be changed so
so I'll go back to what I meant to say
we're going yes or no do you accept the
language as written for lines 15 through
24.
yes representative Stringham
um I I prefer what you just described so
we'll you you're open to a modification
you don't so you're a no on just
accepting this language well I'm I'm
still listening
so I'll say no thank you
uh representative Weiler yes or no on
those lines
I don't see a problem on 27 and 28 uh
it's it's a request of accurate
qualified architect honor before March
1st and shall collaborate to issue a
request to procure a contractor to build
the resulting construction project
that's assumes in my mind after you have
the design it doesn't mean they have to
be done at the same moment yeah so it's
The Logical way to read it so you're a
yes on 15 through 24. uh representative
Wallner
no I'm not are you open to tweaking it
to limit it to Simply site evaluation
I I I think that's what I brought up
with site location first
um and as far as
money in there I'd have to think about
that for a little while longer and I
don't know that 400 000 is the right
amount but that I would replace that
whole section with
um do you have language right now that
you can offer the committee
we we we're on a March one doesn't
change because we're
still talking
I couldn't
so you're you're you're you're a no and
you're a no on a simple modification to
just leave site evaluation
and in the in the dollar amount you're
you're no one either is the dollar
amount 400 000. I I would wag it at 400
000. would you have a better wag
I don't have the slightest idea what
what it would be I would need some
someone who knew
about um I mean someone like from
administrative Services because that was
the right amount all right 50 years of
judgment like 400 000 is not a bad whack
uh representative tolersky do you accept
the language is written lines 15 through
24. I'm a no on it is written I would be
open to sing you're open to a
modification representative nordgren
you you accept that language as is
no I accept change in the language
you're open to tweaking it
representative Mooney
pose leaving it as is and also you
brought up a good point that um I know
our discussions could go on in
perpetuity in fact it doesn't change the
date it actually brings the date closer
March 1st actually comes closer with
every moment that we're here
unfortunately so I like representative
Weiler proposed moving this amendment to
our exec session
thank you
okay I I'm I'm so sorry I'm just not
there yet so uh that I my head count is
four four on accepting the language is
is uh for against and now I'm gonna
explore a tweak in a uh and an effort to
get us to say yes to one another
if we changed on line 16
2 million
to four hundred thousand
and we could put a not to exceed in
there just to really you know make that
more clear
uh I don't think the department tries to
waste money so we could make that a not
to exceed four hundred thousand dollars
and on line 17 leave for the purpose of
site evaluation there because we all
agree that's important and then strike
architect consultation and on 18
delete from the word development through
the word
what through just design options
development of design options so that
would read for the purpose of site
evaluation for replacement facility for
the sununu Youth Center
that that that is my proposed
alternative language
would you accept that representative
hole
so if I'm reading if I'm hearing what
you said and I'll restate it for
clarification right 16 is now four
hundred thousand dollars Seventeen we
strike out architect consultation and
development of design options
my concern then is lines 18 and 19 the
department shall develop two design
options we're still mandating that that
happened but we didn't fund it so I
think there's a conflict right a
technical conflict
um that I don't know what to do with
okay so so how about if we strike on
line 19
um
for the shell develop design options
because the rest of this is kind of
clarifying on the site evaluation piece
of this for the site evaluation it's
helpful for them to know
starting on 18 on to 19 the department
for possibilities
for two possibilities a facility with a
capacity of six to twelve and a capacity
of 12 to 18. so at least they know what
they're evaluating I am okay with the
proposed four hundred thousand dollars
for site evaluation to consider two
design options right not architect not
go do detailed engineering drawings but
two conceptual right
and have those as information to present
back to the legislature because
yesterday we spent a lot of time talking
about who's making the decision on where
this goes I don't think there was
agreement amongst the entire division
that the legislature should be making
the decision ultimately on where this is
so the site evaluation and the design
options coming back to us is a good
thing so so my disclaimer on this as we
go flying by is that I know that Mr
Ripple is listening he's following the
antenna he's following the
strikethroughs and when he gets to
writing an amendment to the amendment
he'll he'll he he's probably going to
have a tweak in there that makes it
smooth without killing the intent so
you do that all the time so that that's
where I'm a member of your intent as
discussed okay so uh representative
Stringham modified language would you be
open to that yes or no
um
uh subject to seeing it yes okay
representative Mooney
yes with the caveat though that I think
by taking out the original language we
move further away from Senate bill one
but the answer to your question is yes
okay I think that was a true statement
representative Weiler yes representative
walner
I think I want to see the language but
yes I think I can go with that thank you
for that representative yes upon
reviewing it representative Morgan yes
thank you okay so good uh that part's
unanimous let's let's skinny up the
section on appropriation to to put 400
000 for begin the side evaluation
okay then paragraph four line 25 through
the key thing that this does the most
powerful aspect of this whole section
from my point of view is that final
sentence the sysc shall immediately be
closed for detention or admission of any
child when a replacement facility is
sufficiently completed the children can
be legal and safely housed there that
way we're not facing the guillotine of
an of another date we're just saying
let's let's do the replacement
uh is there any other part of lines 25
through 31
that that anyone wants to discuss
Mr chair as I pointed out earlier and
words matter and yeah versus
um some sort of proposal right are very
different to me so so
I'm not disagreeing I just need words on
line 28 the return requests a change
procure to proposal yes please
okay and and the in the and the only
disclaimer there is we don't know the
words that our state uses but the term
request for proposal makes
sense to me
so hopefully our state has a similar
word
okay so you're okay with that with that
change in that word I am representative
Stringham
yeah yes representative Mooney yes
Weiler
representative Wallner
I'm going to read it but I think with
the word change yeah okay Yep this is
all content contingent upon reading it
yes yes yes representative yes okay
again we got some unanimity with the one
word change on line 28 for requests for
to procure to request for proposal
then on line 32 this is the commission
I recommend we just keep the whole
commission I mean you know we we're
going to go ahead and start the
evaluation process I think this
commission is a vital part of it this
commission is limited in its Authority
it doesn't make any decisions it's going
to be able to write reports it's going
to be able to propose legislation it's
going to engage the communities so so I
think that does all the things that
we've said we want done and that's lines
1 through 33.
is is there an alternative point of view
yes sir
uh just to comply with 1449 can we just
make uh
um
G and H representative
um rather than representatives and and
perhaps add one House member make it
four and three or something oh okay
let's do one at a time on line 15 and I
think the same thing is going to be true
on line 17. the the word is currently
plural Representatives right so so in in
the way that I've written things that
has been accepted I don't know if my
fifth grade English teacher would agree
but I would put the S of Representatives
in parentheses so it could be a
representative or Representatives
without specifying a number and the
reason for not specifying a number is is
just so that we can do things rationally
if they really get fixated on Hampstead
they can bother the Hampstead people
without trying to get a Concord person
to show up
so so what does that work Mr Ripple if
we just put the S of Representatives in
the parentheses
I think it could
as representative Stringham points out
so RSA 1449 caps the number of members
of the commission at 15 and contains
various other requirements Senate bill
one
actually had language saying
notwithstanding RSA 1449 that I noticed
is missing from this so I would add that
to this language as well tell me what
line item you would put notwithstanding
um
at the beginning of the sentence that's
at the end of line five the commission
shall consists of the following members
I would say notwithstanding RSA 1449 the
commission shall consist of the
following members okay I'm I'm okay with
that I'm not sure what it means but
uh I like saying yes so so so lines 30
to excuse me one through 33 on page two
we've suggested tweaks to add the RSA on
line five and to change representatives
to the parenthetical so that we can get
the right number is there any any
discussion
representative hole yes or no
okay representative Mooney
fine and I would just point out on line
five fire safety has been added per our
discussions yesterday
well yes we added uh other relevant
factors too so yeah right yes yes ma'am
um representative Weiler yes or no
represent Wallner yes
thank you
yes question Mr chair um yes what's
three
ship of the department to this come
did they have any X official role or
what
what's their relationship
well if I read line 10 properly C the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services or designee is is on
this and I imagine the designee would be
something that looks like a Mr ribson
but yeah
do you have another question do you want
to follow I think that's
that's the chairman yes
is there
for the full committee so we're getting
very close I'm so sorry I I know you're
a fighter pilot
right
now
yes sir I thought I'd have a
I I haven't do I thought I'd have a
decision two years ago so uh okay so
you're okay with that I think we're all
okay with lines one through thirty three
and then the rest of it gets into
repeals and effective dates and and uh I
I think we're okay with those
all right
representative hole Stringham
Wyler Waller okay
all right so we have a proposal uh if we
come back and it's exactly like this
can I expect you to vote Yes on this yes
or no
yes
yes or no
so that's a yes could you speak into the
microphone
yes if it's exactly like written just
agreed upon thank you representative
tolerski I just wanted to clarify go
ahead upon reviewing it yes I would be
able to support it upon reviewing it all
right thank you representative norgren
yes thank you all right and that's
that's always implied you know you have
to be able to read it okay so so uh I
think with that uh I'm ready to to to to
to to to recommend to the whole house or
excuse me the whole committee that we
adopt uh what will be the modification
to zero four five four as we've
discussed and have Mr Ripple go make
that happen
uh and then the rest of the idea options
49 and uh two uh or 527 I'm gonna I'm
gonna recess that to the next work
session
any comments if you're going to have
another work session then I have to
dismiss the rest of the committee no no
next week we're not going to do that
we're we're SB we're we're acting on sb1
sir we're not we're gonna we're gonna
postpone 49 and 527 until a future work
session that's already being calendared
all right so my point is I've had the
rest of this committee waiting around
this is a result of this
and there is nothing to report I I I
believe there is I believe that we're
working on a fresh Amendment it'll be
coming back as soon as it can and and I
think we have as long as there's no
typographical error in there or uh we're
we're gonna we're gonna recommend to the
the committee acceptance I hope we have
a quorum
okay the way we've been delaying all
this all right so I'd like to adjourn
this meeting
division three is now adjourned how much
time do you think Mr Ripple
I think no more than an hour
yep
I have to inform the rest of the finance
committee
that we'll meet in an hour
or sooner
if there's enough of them here to
to pay attention
how many are there any out people out in
the other room that we could inform
foreign
oh that is
I
foreign
thank you
thank you all right while we're here you
can all read through the amendment
uh zero four six five H uh we'll be
voting on that hopefully it has all the
corrections everybody wants and
everybody's got a chance to read it so
we see that all the changes were made as
requested
I guess we're waiting for a couple more
members and then we'll get going
wait a minute maybe one more member
so Mr chair just information I I've read
this I I think this is an accurate
representation of what we agreed to this
afternoon
about the other division three people
representative Stringham
please give me about one more minute
please okay representative Hall
on line 29.
on line 29 still reading it thank you
all right we'll wait a bit
okay we don't have the parentheses with
NS we got one or more Representatives
yes sir they had a better grammar person
than me
one or more representative Jim
thank you
yes
foreign
made again
tell me when you finish Mary Jane that's
all right it's okay
I'm good hey how's that um so I look
neat now
all set
foreign
back from Recess
we have before us Amendment 0465 h
or Amendment or amendment to Senate bill
one
representative
Edwards is recognized for a motion uh
thank you Mr chair I move
otpa using Amendment
0-465 Hotel
second
that's ought to pass motion and a second
about to pass further discussion on the
amendment and which replaces the bill
um Mr chair we we uh we had a meeting
again this afternoon at division three
uh we went back through the amendment
that we had agreed on yesterday we made
some modifications to that to just make
sure that we were all aligned on the
limits of the initial appropriation to
do side evaluation upon reaching
agreement I I think there's strong
support for this amendment because I
believe it reflects what we agreed to
further questions further discussion
representative Heath thank you just a
little concern that I have here where it
says the commission shall submit a
preliminary support on or before
November 1st
um 23 and a final report
um 2024
I'm hoping that on or before is really
what we're talking about it seems like
we want to get going on this
am I correct you are correct thank you
let's try it this way seeing none are
you ready for the question
the motion before us is
to adopt the amendment zero four six
five H to Senate bill one
which will replace the bill
motion is ought to pass as amended with
Amendment zero four six five h
there's no further discussion the clerk
will call the roll on the motion of
ought to pass as amended is this on a
pass or Auto passes amended ought to
pass as amended all right you want to
join the amendment all right yeah that's
that's the point I'm trying to make all
right shall we have a vote on the
amendment first you want a roll call or
a show of hands hands all right show of
hands all that are in favor of amendment
zero four six five
hands down your name any opposed
call it unanimous
we will adopt Amendment 0465 now the
motion is ought to pass as amended on
Amendment 0465-h the clerk will call the
roll on ought to pass as amended
representative McGuire
yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes
uh representative yes
representative walner
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes
in terms of hatch yes
president of who it yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative uh Wyler yes
Mr chair the vote is 23-0
didn't think we had that many people
well all right
that's how many people it comes up to
Visa all right very good
the report is adopted and the calendar
is being kept open for the report so you
have it set to go
um Ms Clayman has the committee report
thank you
all right is there any further business
to come before us the other bills that
we're going to be in division three will
be kept for another day
and we won't be able to get to them
today so
there's no other business to come before
us we are adjourned thank you very much
for all waiting thank you for your
patience it's a forerunner of what we
need for the grueling tasks ahead did
you do the main motion yes
same same difference yes she did the uh
okay very good thank you
thank you Mary Jane
I apologize
foreign